We're going to go live
three,
two,
one.
Tom Papa is obviously some sort of a
nicotine junkie.
He's using a knife made out of a nail to
scratch.
Open the box so he can get at these
cigars like Ben Franklin use this knife
to open up wine and once that's from the
pygmies.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They made it for me.
Look at their little handle.
My good friend Justin Wren,
who's been on the podcast a few times.
He's this amazing guy that does.
He makes wells for the pygmies.
He's.
He was a former UFC fighter knife fights
for Bella tour.
Uh,
uh,
he's in the heavyweight division.
This big teddy bear of a guy,
like the fucking nicest guy ever wanted
me.
Oh yeah.
And he goes to the Congo and builds
wells and we've,
we've helped them out.
We cut some people that donate bitcoin,
which by the way is worth more money
now.
So what I'm going to do is take whatever
it's worth now and just give it to the
Congo people.
You gotta wait this week.
I've got to wait.
JP Morgan Guide screwed it up.
He fucked up.
Understand the bitcoin and just make it
go up and down fast.
Um,
Ooh.
They look beautiful.
They look luscious.
How many people?
This is what,
this is what you offer somebody right
before you screw them.
Joe Average,
cigar,
strange.
Stop.
And think about this.
When you are buying a cigar,
like let's think about the kind of
people that you think of.
Smoking cigars,
I think of like a Jay z type character
on a yacht,
right?
Looking out over the.
Oh,
the beautiful ocean going,
I did it.
I fucking did it.
I mean there's no denying I'm here.
He's got a gold rope around his neck and
he's pumped up.
He's got some champagne or maybe a nice
Martini.
So gentlemen sitting there,
just go with what the fuck.
Get any better.
This is it.
I did it.
I mean,
come on.
He wins.
He wins so hard and that's the beauty of
the cigar is eve.
You could be in your little crappy yard
and smoking a cigar.
You feel like that.
But here's my thought.
When we associate the cigar with that
guy,
think about who makes a cigar.
You're talking about people who live in
tiny villages,
they'd get paid almost nothing that are
rolling these things together.
God bless them.
How much are they getting paid?
I mean,
I know there's some,
there's some places in Miami where you
can actually go and you can actually
watch them make cigars.
They'll roll up cigars.
It's pretty bad ass progressive.
But like,
who is,
who is profiting from this?
Like uh,
yeah,
the big,
the whoever owns the big giant tobacco
company.
Right?
But they need those people that roll
those things.
You do,
but you know,
the little guy who rolling the things,
he,
he's,
you know,
just making a little living,
doing his little thing he did.
He can't build the whole tobacco
companies,
corporate.
Tom,
Tom.
It's essentially like he's a little
worker.
You need to be and you meet the Queen
Bee.
Right.
But
isn't that person a lot?
Like what we were talking about with
standup,
like the comedian is the one who
actually makes the product was the
comedy clubs were getting all the money.
Right.
And you were in poverty and the comedy
club was balling out of control.
Yeah.
When you feel like this is bullshit.
Yes and no,
because in New York,
as you remember,
there was a big riot,
a big.
Everyone was like,
these clubs are paying us 20 bucks a
spot that been paying us that forever.
Screw them,
they make money,
blah,
and I had a hard time with it because I
felt like what they're giving us in a
place to go and do stand up every night
and have an audience there.
The value I was getting from my act was
so much more valuable than the $20 I was
getting paid.
I didn't care about the 20th.
I wanted them to give me a place where I
could go work on my act and then take
that to some other city or some other
bigger gig and that's where I would make
my mind.
So you know what I mean?
It was.
It wasn't purely like,
screw the man,
the man is giving me a comedy club and
is run this place for 30 years so I can
roll in on a Wednesday and have 200
people.
Well there.
Well there's certainly,
I think at different field that you have
for places that are,
like you're saying,
if you are an icehouse comedian,
you can essentially have like a
partnership but the ice house,
like I feel like I have a bit of a
partnership with the Ice House.
Yes.
Will you,
do you sell it out?
Yeah,
and I love that place and I love Bob The
guy who owns it and I don't mean a
partnership like I have an ownership in
it,
but I feel like there is,
I have a bit of an obligation I think we
all do to perform at the great clubs
just to just to keep them floating and
keep everybody happy and in t because
you can and because it's good for you
and it's good for me and it's good for
everybody instead of a partnership.
Maybe.
Maybe that's the best word,
but there's some sort of a inexorable
relationship.
You cannot separate them
for sure.
Like there's some cities,
you know,
like a hilarity and Cleveland.
Right.
I love that club.
Love the using place.
Nixa greatest guy,
great food too.
They're also,
they,
they're like family.
It literally is great people.
I have no interest of going to Cleveland
and playing a theater because if I,
if everybody comes up and jumps on nick,
then I'd rather draw,
spend a couple days,
I'll make the same money.
Pretty much I like that is a
relationship.
Like we've had a relationship throughout
the years for me to jump in and seems
weird.
It does,
right?
But there's some other places that,
uh,
you don't feel like that.
I mean,
you know,
also your thing with the ice house,
it's like you say you're playing the ice
house now and fight tonight.
It's sold out before it tonight and now
he's got a really good business going
there,
you know?
Awesome.
I've been able to get guys like you and
they're onstage
and,
or comes in a lot now.
It's like you get people to realize like
this is an amazing place to practice and
the people are so cool.
It's like the best.
There's a difference in um,
like the feel of the audience like La.
It's like,
wow,
we're at the college tour,
believe it.
We're an ice house.
It's like,
wow,
we're up to see a show.
Really is is a different field.
Totally different.
Yeah.
You feel like you're a almost a little
on the road.
Yeah.
You know what's like that to Oxnard
Oxnard?
Do you ever done that place king,
amazing club,
an hour outside of La and you're on the
road,
a comedy magic?
Same.
Same thing.
You know?
Any place where when you wake up in the
morning you're like,
oh,
I got to drive there on the road,
but you know those gigs,
math are so fucking important because
you have to have a shitty gigs to
appreciate,
to appreciate the nice ones.
Oh,
absolutely.
On every Gig is good.
Yeah.
Even the worst ones,
but back to your a cigar thing,
you know there are these little workers
that are probably making $2 a day.
That's the point.
We're all in this stuff.
I mean,
I'm just guessing.
I don't really know.
Maybe my dead off and maybe these people
are highly compensated.
Skilled labor.
Well,
it's probably layers of it.
There's probably a guy who's really good
at it.
You know,
who runs everybody who's been there for
30 years as a role and his mother,
motherfucker could just wash.
Right?
You know,
dudes who could just roll joints.
Ever meet those guys.
So impressive.
Like a cigarette.
They slide it out their mouth.
I have no skill.
I am fucking ape fingered retarded when
it comes to rolling joints.
I used to be good at it,
but I watched some people like Tony
Hinchcliffe gonna enroll a fucking fat
joint yet Jamie.
First roles.
Goddamn good joint.
I used to be good at it.
You know what the problem with me,
man?
I got one of those roller things,
those little machine with the fingers.
The best ones are with the fingers.
There's one year I have that.
You could go like that and you put the
rolling paper in,
you put the uh,
the,
the Wieden and then you know,
you lick the paper and then you just go
like that bump bump.
And it does it all really all by itself.
Yeah.
It rolls it up.
So advanced.
Yeah.
It's so good.
I'm like,
I'm not rolling this out my hand.
What am I an asshole when you're smoking
by yourself or with sticks when you're
by yourself to your role or do you just
take like one?
I already rolled.
Are you buying them already rolled from
la speed.
We'd for all your delivery services of
headspring when you buy them already
rolled like you don't have to think
about it.
I don't want to think about shit.
Yeah,
but some people have the ritual,
the ritual of that.
I used to love the deep it on an album I
used to and they had albums.
What has replaced the album for rolling?
We'd on and then it went to CD cover.
You would do it on a CD cover and now
people use those actual weed theme
trace.
That seems kind of Corny to me.
Yeah.
Like you should steal some shit from a
cafeteria.
Have like a pirates of the Caribbean or
nate's little tray.
You know what you should have man.
He get one of them aluminum ones from
prison because you're in a prison of
your own mind,
man.
A real like standard issue.
Aluminum,
prison trade for fake mashed potatoes
went to prison.
Of your own mind,
man,
you got to free your mind.
Do you have a cutter?
A do not.
Oh yeah,
I know I do.
I could show it off.
When I think about the cigar though,
I don't think of a Jay Z so much as a
like it's a wonderful life like the
banker and that's wonderful line.
We had a box with a cutter in it and
some other bullshit that I bring that
in.
I can bite it off if you bite it off
though.
I feel like it's one of those things.
When I started,
I'm out of school.
I worked in advertising for a little
while and I used to have to go to this
nursing home.
We did.
It was small advertising and we would go
to a nursing home and we would do all
the ad campaign for this guy who owns
like five nursing homes.
He was a really rich guy and he looked a
little like a frog.
He was like an older guy came up in the
war and he used to,
you know,
first you started with trucks,
now he owned nursing homes and he was
just like an old school guy,
big glasses and he always had a cigar
all day long.
He'd walk around with a cigar and his
mouth just chomping on it.
Not what he would just chomp,
chomp,
it and it would be like kind of scuzzy
at the end,
but then eventually no cutter at the
end.
He'd been chewing at show long.
We just spit it out and then light it
up.
Hmm.
Yeah.
What a Weirdo.
Fine.
Don't worry about Jamie.
It might be the other.
Combined it off.
Don't worry about it in the kitchen
doing it already.
Yeah.
We'll just bite it off.
Just go old school.
Yeah.
Old School.
Bugsy shingle type.
We do feel like a big shot with a cigar.
Why is that?
Why do you feel like a big shot?
I don't know.
I feel gross spitting it out till I know
here's a tissue weed in their son.
Jamie,
can we find out whether or not cigar
rollers are abused and underpaid?
Scar industry's going to be pissed at
us.
No.
Sure.
Or weird thing,
right?
It's like a cigar is like a a thing at
that point.
Right.
But it's also like a,
like a guy thing or.
Yes.
Chick who can hang thing bro.
She smoked cigar.
Come on girl with Leggy and open blouse.
Like wearing glasses,
like smoking a cigar with men's rolex
hat on like a fucking dodgers hat on.
Yes.
He's screaming facts about the broncos.
Yeah.
With like those cheerleader type socks.
Go all the way up to her knees.
No,
that girl's fun to hang with one night.
But you don't want that girl for the
long haul.
Well she's a sprinter.
Not a marathon runner.
Yeah.
You want to date an ultra marathon
runner so it's just slow and,
and they just keep
that pace and they will not quit arms in
tight.
Just go and little steps with no
underwear on and sweat socks with your
shirt on.
And she's smoking a cigar.
Like,
all right,
you're not coming to thanksgiving.
I don't think this is going to make it.
This one's not going to be.
Yeah,
you're going to be fun for a little
while,
but it's like a rollercoaster.
Would you want to ride a rollercoaster
eight hours a day for the rest of your
life?
You'll be nauseous all the time.
Yeah,
I mean that's.
That's the function that crazy people
have in your life.
They're valuable,
but you don't want to be around them
constantly.
Now a hell of a lot of funding.
You pack up the car and go visit once in
a while and that's it.
Yeah,
pretty crazy.
People are exhausting,
man.
Totally exhausting.
I remember this crazy girl once and it
went on longer than it should and she
was intensely fun.
I mean crazy.
Just,
you know,
insane.
Everything about it was fun and insane.
Yeah,
and I stayed in too long and by the end
of it I was like,
he just got it.
You got to go.
I was almost in tears.
That was like,
you gotta get Outta here.
I can't.
I can't live like this because it wasn't
just the like the crazy fun drought.
It was directed at you at a certain
point and they want them to put the
crazy on you and analyze and fight and
stuff.
Some people definitely want to fight.
I can't live in with fight fighter.
I'm not either.
Some people think that you're supposed
to.
That's how a relationship is supposed to
be fighting.
Do you somehow or another you don't care
about each other because if you care you
get upset.
So very weird sort of dynamic.
The man and woman relationship dynamic
of things that people think you
shouldn't,
shouldn't expect the way people behave
or don't behave the way they talk to you
or don't talk to you like it's very
hard.
You know?
It's weird.
It's as if it's all the same.
If any friendship is the same.
Yeah.
Don't let,
don't let people be mean to you.
Don't let them fucking beat you down.
You'll shit at you.
But some people like if you grow up in a
home that fights all the time,
you get used to that and then you.
It's not a big deal.
She was,
this girl was she fight screaming,
yelling at and like as soon as it was,
it was done,
she'd be fine.
Just like I have some coffee and just
sit there and I'd be shaking like,
oh my God,
why did she say you?
I'm not good with that kind of tension
that at all.
I used to date this girl would get
really mad,
really mad and want to fight and then
once,
once there was some sort of resolution
should immediately turned docile.
It was very odd,
like she'd be aggressive to like start
some sort of altercation,
but you could calm the altercation down,
shut it down.
Yeah.
But you had to almost shut it down by
just saying or you're not going to do
this.
I'm not going to talk like this.
Like this child was young.
Sorry.
I needed to learn like how to talk to
people or how to manage situations.
Like sometimes something's happening
between two people,
like,
uh,
you're,
you're upset about something.
And instead of
thinking about how you're conveying your
thought to them,
all you think of is what you want to
happen.
I want you to shut the fuck up.
I know.
Even though you want someone to shut the
fuck up.
The problem is when you say that you're
not really thinking about communicating
with them through their eyes wants
anyone to say shut the fuck up,
but we.
Because we want people to shut the fuck
up and you can't deal with it.
I,
I'm know.
Yeah.
Is a point you don't want.
You don't care what their needs are.
You just stop.
Well,
it's.
Well it's also like when people want
people to do things so they want people.
There's,
there's the,
the mindset of you wanting a result.
You want someone to behave a certain way
instead of thinking about them as like
your equal.
I can just another human being and
instead of thinking like I have to get
what I want,
like what is it that you want?
Okay,
what,
what happened here?
Like why are we pass?
I find like impasse getting older,
that thing I'm more aware of your.
It's that big part of not thinking about
you all the time.
You're always think,
especially when you're young and you're
like coming up and you're doing,
it's just me,
me,
me it,
because you're just trying to survive.
You're trying to figure.
You don't even know what you want when
you shut that part down and think about
the person across from you.
Yeah,
it opens up the whole world,
but it's a difficult thing to learn when
you're young.
Contradictory to success like you think,
but not like it's.
I think it's like if you don't think
about yourself,
no one will.
You know,
there's that kind of thought process.
Just get really good at shit the best
way.
Here's the ironic thing,
one of the best ways to get really good
at Shit is shutting that voice down.
Yeah,
good.
Shout it out.
Especially with the voice.
That voice like me,
me,
me and this and that,
and I want people to listen to me.
Shut that thing down.
The more you can shut that thing down
into more whatever you do,
you concentrate on it going to work and
nobody does it perfect.
Nobody does it perfectly.
It's not only that they don't do a
perfect.
It's that you have to constantly reteach
yourself that you have to constantly
bring yourself back,
bring yourself back.
It's a.
it's a.
it's a trick.
It's an ongoing exercise.
It really is and that's why it's like A.
I was watching this interview with Nate
Diaz,
UFC fighter.
He's hilarious and nate was talking
about watching himself on the ultimate
fighter from 10 years ago and he's like,
please shut that shit off.
He goes,
anybody watch a video of yourself from
10 years ago?
You'd be like,
shut that shit up.
And I was thinking he's so right.
That's such an obvious thing like nobody
likes to see themselves from a long time
ago because we're all a work in
progress,
but when you were in that moment when
that video
was taken of you,
you thought you had to go and on,
you thought you were doing right?
For sure.
I mean,
right now we think we're in the moment
like we're doing fine,
but if you were to look back at this,
there'd be something wrong.
I'm upset that the cigar has two bands.
I feel I took the first band off
immediately,
dark and go fuck itself because of that.
It's too fancy.
It's outrageous.
I am really enjoying to bands.
How about you take the money from one of
these bands and pay those dudes?
Roll this mother far such a socialist.
I'm turning comedy as I get older.
It's happening.
Alright.
Yeah.
I'm shifting.
Red Shifting.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
what I shift towards lately more than
anything is like kindness to our fellow
humans.
That is the exact word I have been using
all month.
Act out of kindness,
politicians,
people,
grocers,
my family.
Just be kind.
Yeah,
and I think the more we recognize that,
the more we see evidence of that,
even an idea even in like groups or you
know,
chunks of people that share our mindset
on other things and we don't want to
call it,
we don't want to call them out on it,
like say if you're a republican and
there's like some Republican candidate
or something that's running for
president,
but they're really shady in one way or
the corrupt or what,
and you know,
you don't want to talk about it because
it's a part of your party.
That's insane.
You can't.
Yeah.
You.
Well,
you know,
tribalism inside our own civilization is
fucking bananas.
I feel like that's like the most
disturbing thing of the all the
discourse now is that people are so
entrenched in these teams.
You're a sucker if you're that in,
on any of these teams.
No team is partly,
you've got a flow.
Do you think that's because people were
scared and so they feel like they feel
more comfort in being a part of some
rigid team,
like,
like say if you're a right.
That's what I see in like a lot of these
white supremacists see fear.
You guys were walking in their holdings
flags and there were these torches and
they're yelling things.
See fear.
Yeah,
I really do.
It's a big part of what it is.
They're coming for me.
They're coming for us.
They're pushing us out.
We're supposed to all be the same thing.
We looked different.
Jesus Christ.
That's it.
I mean,
and all the other differences that we
have like left and right and ideologies
and how can you be all in on any
political organization?
Like how can you,
how it's faith.
It's just like,
what's that a Malian on weed.
Well,
alright,
team weed.
You can go for it.
You really don't understand it like you
really have.
And what's really upsetting about it is
it goes completely against what we're
talking about.
Listening to the other person,
like really listening to them.
There's a,
there's a guy on my block,
older guy,
he's retired,
he's got his little dog.
He walks this little dog every day and
he always,
Hey,
you know,
we've only been there a couple of years.
Good Morning Tom.
Morning Bob
and he just walks with his dog and he's
just like this nice.
He's the guy from.
He's in my movie of my life.
He's the extra.
The walks the guy.
My wife saw that he had a trump poster
in his garage and my wife was all in on
Hillary.
He was like,
I don't think I can.
I can talk to him.
I was like,
yes you can.
That doesn't mean any.
So what?
So that's what he went for.
Him Did it.
So what?
He's bald,
the guy with the dog,
he's a loving person who really is
excited to see us in our children and
our dog in the morning.
Stop using that thing,
this one isolated thing as to as a
marker for whether or not this person
can enter your life in any way.
The only way you should is if that
person is trying to force that on you
and make you believe what they believe
and if you don't support trump,
then they hate you and then then it
becomes.
It's virtually interchangeable with
religion.
Yeah,
right.
Like if your next door neighbor's a Jew
and the guy on the other side of you is
a baptist and you're an atheist and
there's no reason why you can't all be
great friends,
great friends hanging out was like,
Hey,
what's up?
You guys want to come over?
We're going to do some hot dogs or
whatever that are kosher.
Who gives a shit?
Who gives a shit shit and isn't it more
effective?
If you are really politically minded and
really want your,
your really love Hillary and you love
what she stood for and you want that,
isn't it more effective to invite this
guy into your life and let him see that
he has a lot more in common with this
liberal family.
Sit at the end of the block.
Then putting up walls and keeping them
out.
I think that people were given a real
disservice by being forced to choose
only on on one side or the other.
One of them is Donald Trump and the
other one is Hillary Clinton.
This,
this like hustle system that they put
together.
A two party system is the reason why
it's so difficult because a party has to
choose a candidate you have to vote on
in the primaries,
so you have to be registered.
Not that many people are thinking what
the actual numbers of people that vote
in the primaries.
It's a fraction of the people that vote
in the general election.
Right?
And that's a fraction of the population.
And so if you forced to choose between
like this really lackluster candidate
and people say,
oh,
she had all this experience,
regardless of what you think about
Hillary supported her or not you,
you'd have to look at it objectively and
say,
well,
she's a deeply flawed candidate.
I mean,
she had a lot of issues.
There's a lot of credibility issues.
She didn't support gay marriage until
2013.
That was one of my big red flag because
I'm like,
how?
Why do you care?
Like if you really care,
if you really think,
I really believe that gay people
shouldn't have the same rights in terms
of like bonding in a relationship than a
straight person.
Well,
that's a crazy person's idea.
Like what do you give a shit that
doesn't make any sense?
What is it?
Why is it,
there's no proof that marriage is
putting this gigantic burden on our,
on us and why do you want,
what do you care about how these people
live?
Why,
why is leave him be so kind to me.
And then like when you hear the
difference between what Cami said about
the investigation and when the results
were versus what she said,
like there's a video where it plays it
back to back where she says that
everything was fine and everything was
no big deal and he was like his fucking
huge deal and they like,
she would say that,
you know,
this,
there was no evidence of this.
And he said there was evidence of this
and multiple occasions and it's like you
look at the two of them back to back,
Yo,
what the fuck man?
And people got mad at me for making a
big deal out of that.
Like there's a lot of people that say,
hey man,
you know,
you're partially responsible when people
like you for pointing out all this
Hillary Clinton Shit.
Like,
no,
we're talking about reality.
Not are not responsible for reality
sucking will.
It comes to that,
but the idea is the opposite is don't
talk about it at all and pretend it
doesn't exist.
Problem
with,
with all these people being pitted
against each other,
they can't see the other side and have a
little bit of flow.
I feel like it also has become this.
It's almost like news is entertainment
now when we watch a 24 hour news
programs and stuff,
it's like rooting for the bears are
rooting for the steelers.
You know what I mean?
Like it's become this passionate,
you know,
sport,
entertaining sport.
It's kind of a,
it's kind of upsetting,
but I mean it's very upsetting that Sean
Hannity Guy.
Yeah.
How has that guy any more different than
a.
like a local football broadcaster who's
really excited about the Patriots?
Patriots is Tina asked,
oh my God is going to be great.
They're not going to be stopped
patriots.
They say what they want about Brady
didn't plate those balls.
It's completely.
Yeah,
no,
he's like a fucking Rah Rah Republican
character,
right?
Just like almost like a football guy.
One hundred percent all in whatever the
fuck the Republican point is.
He's all in and you're not going to
convince him to like the New York
giants.
He's a patriots guy.
That's just the way it goes.
But I really feel like you got to go
through life and rather than thinking
about,
and I want to be too preachy,
but not to be.
You shouldn't be going by.
My party should be going by the acts of
these people.
So everybody,
everybody's like,
uh,
you.
So you can hate that.
That pruitt is going after public lands,
enrolling back all this EPA stuff.
And then you see trump or make a deal
yesterday with Pelosi and Schumer saying
we're going to try and make sure that
these Daca kids are allowed to stay it
through everybody.
Like,
wait,
what?
But I know,
but I still have to hate them.
But Nancy Pelosi's office making a deal
with them.
Well,
that's how you should act.
It should be.
He should be allowed to do something
kind.
He should be allowed to.
You should be allowed to call him out
when he does something shitty.
It shouldn't be just this blanket.
I love the guy.
No matter what.
Well you.
Someone said,
I forget who it was,
I forget who the person was that had
this idea,
but the idea was that one of the good
things about trump would be that he is
concerned with public opinion and so if
he floats an idea out there and it's not
popular or it's really damaging public
opinion of him,
he'll take a second look at which is a
very non politician like thing to do.
You know,
when people point to terrible things
that he's done in the past almost as
like evidence that he can evolve,
you know,
like evidence that he's a sociopath,
we're fucking doomed.
If that's the case,
we're doomed.
If human beings and human beings in
general,
general right and we're doomed with
mean.
If you can't learn at 70 is,
is it over?
Like there's a difference when you're
20,
you could figure things out when you're
30,
you know,
I'm better than I was when I was 20
know,
but when you get to 70 no,
then it's no.
Yeah,
there's no more learning in like a super
extreme scenario.
Like the president of the free world is
terrifying.
I mean he's the leader of the free
world.
Yeah.
At 70,
at 70,
and with a bunch of people that hate
them and then talking about like
shipping immigrant kids back.
There's people that were born here when
they were to know there are brought here
rather when they were two,
they were born another country.
They don't know the other country at all
and they'll send them back to it.
It's crazy scary.
It's very scary.
It's scary because it's not.
There's no empathy to that.
Like these people are terror.
It's one thing if someone is some sort
of a dangerous criminal,
we'll.
If that's the case,
they should be in fucking jail.
That's what jail is for.
Why would you just set them free in
Mexico?
That sounds crazy.
And we have this girl in her life who
was born here,
she was part of that and has since
gotten her citizenship.
So she was safe but just recently.
So as soon as they came in and started
saying where we might send them back,
it was like Tara.
Tara was like hiding in our house,
like can I just sleep here?
She was so nervous just to sleep in her
little apartment somewhere because he
thought they were gonna come and get her
to.
The friend of mine is a contractor and
you went to Home Depot and now was in.
He's in Home Depot.
He gets out of his car and these ice
guys.
I mean this guy is a distinguished
looking handsome man in his fifties and
speaks perfect English.
They,
they flash their fucking badges,
you know,
he makes them shows the first they just
said you have to.
And he goes,
listen,
just came up to him in the parking lot.
He listen dumb ass.
He's like,
he's former military.
He was like,
I told them because I was in the
military,
like,
you guys can't just do this.
This is not something you do.
You don't just come up to someone and
ask,
where were you born?
Is that what they.
That's how they led up to him.
Were you born?
Show me your Id.
Oh my God.
And he was like,
what the fuck are you guys doing?
He goes,
I'm going to show you my military id.
Okay,
here you go.
Now here's my id.
Okay,
now what the fuck are you guys doing?
You can't do this because this is
totally illegal.
It's,
it's insane.
Just grabbing people out of their cars
for no reason.
Your life looking brown,
Bro.
You look at over there,
See that's not kind.
Let them Brown Brown.
Were you born?
I asked him where he was born.
We're crazy served in our military.
Exactly the same fucking control.
First of all,
I was born in America.
He was absolutely.
Yeah,
but he has to prove that.
Approve it because he's Brown and.
But just ask him where.
Where did your parents have you?
It's the one thing that you cannot
control.
I shouldn't have immigrants.
Don't use that.
Right,
exactly.
We went right.
We might be anything with immigration.
My parents,
my parents,
parents were born here.
Exactly.
Native Americans are the only ones who
who were legitimately here long enough
to claim it came across the bering land
bridge from Asia.
So for spot it's nobody's fucking
assholes.
Yeah.
Just taking a brown guy.
Right Subaru.
I'm sure if you took those guys with
those officials,
they have to have the same story.
We all came from somewhere else.
I know.
It's insane.
So crazy.
This guy's not doing a crime like you're
just assuming that he's some sort of an
illegal immigrant because he's at home
depot.
Fuck.
He fixes things himself.
He just fucking contract.
He can't be an American.
We just throw our shit out.
He still has the fixes TV.
If that's not.
Is that racial profiling or is that
racist?
I feel like it's more race.
I think it's more racist because look,
racist really means that you are using
power to put people down for the race
and when we say racist is just saying
something shitty about somebody,
it's not really.
It's,
it's when you really have power over
people and use that and that's what that
is.
One hundred percent and it's,
it's like a target and here's the thing,
man,
maybe he's right.
Thirty percent of the time that he does
this,
maybe that cop does that all the time
and catches these guys that are there
that are illegal immigrants and they're
just there to try to hustle and work on
people's houses,
but that's why we have laws.
It's like exact the guy who a waste
wasted resource unless they're
criminals,
they're criminals.
While there are people who were fucked,
fucked at birth,
at birth,
that's the way they came,
right?
They're stuck in some poor country and
they figured out a way to get across the
border illegally.
Can you imagine?
Can you imagine how desperate people
must be in these other countries that
you would you as a father,
you would tell your kids,
go with this man and hopefully get over
to that other country for a better life.
Could you imagine how desperate you
would have to be to tell your children
go,
that is a desperate,
desperate situation and it just is a
roll of the dice that you were born 50
miles that way.
Or like my friend Justin,
who makes these wells for people in the
Congo.
Well,
just
having fresh water changes their life.
The one thing that we absolutely take
for granted,
you give it away free at restaurants.
Exactly did that.
We give away to everybody for free.
The thing that changes their life and
the Congo,
a fresh clean glass of water,
nothing.
Nothing to everything you've put you
clean your asshole.
Whether it was Japanese toilets,
you have one of those.
Oh,
it's the fast,
vast.
I moved into a house.
I didn't.
We didn't know what it was and we were
just looking around and we walked into
the bathroom and the lid open.
Oh,
and it sees you.
It's one of those is warm.
Oh,
it's heaven.
It is.
It's almost sexual because that warm
waters shoot into your asshole and
here's the thing is like an.
There's only an on off button.
It doesn't go,
hey fucker enough,
it's creepy how many people are just
sitting there with rod shooting out of
their ass all stroking their shaft.
Must Be.
It must be like the number one tool for
masturbation and everybody around the
world does it,
but Americans,
it's not right.
The day is not a main thing in America.
Well we prefer to do is chop down trees
and make a fine paper that we smear shit
over asshole.
Walk up and talk about your day with
fecal matter all over the fucking room.
Radically cut down on the amount of
fecal matter available.
If we just had jets of water,
that was the rest of the world.
Just fly it out.
But the rest of you how they do that but
day thing,
which is awkward.
It's like the most ergonomic thing ever
created with metal pipe thing is right
where your asshole goes and there's
nowhere to sit.
It seems much nastier.
The first time you walk into a hotel and
saw that as a kid,
you were like,
I don't care if I'm cleaning or I'm not
doing that.
I was in a hotel in New York City,
I forgot the hotel,
but they had some crazy setup where
there was not just a bad day,
but they had to fucking hoses one on
either side of the bowl when that hard
metal.
So you've got to have a day over here
and you got a bath with these two
fucking carwash hoses right next to the
toilet.
How clean the after me.
But it's like,
I mean he just shoot water everywhere
while you're shooting.
What are you doing with those two?
What did you do it in there?
It's like one the right hand to left
hand and why?
I don't like cleaning my asshole with my
right hand and do it and I have to go
left,
grab this and strangle myself as I
cleaned my,
but I'm not.
I keep my phone and I looked this up
when that happened.
I remember that.
Yeah,
the answer.
I don't know if it's even better than
the day.
It's to clean this shit off the inside
of the toilet.
That many,
not one of them is.
That's why it's so hard to keep it clean
the whole time.
You get the second one's for,
but that's what one of them is for.
That's a
shitty way to do it.
Pardon my pun.
These,
these people are eating the wrong foods.
Oh yeah.
Thank you guys.
Or would you.
Would you ever,
um,
have you ever thought about going to
other countries and doing volunteer
work?
What does that just came out yesterday
or the day before?
You guys talk about shit.
One hundred and 40 town fat bird ton.
One hundred.
One hundred 40 ton.
Oh my God.
Fatberg has been discovered under the
streets of London.
What does that mean?
It's oil,
fat.
Tampons.
Wet Wipes,
diapers.
Oh,
it's a.
and it's stuck in this.
It's like concrete now they said it's
stuck in this pipe.
Oh my 420 burned this size of two
football pitches.
Is that mainly a soccer 100?
It looks like the Globes that bigger or
shorter than American.
I think it's a little longer.
Of course it is.
And wider was found in London sewers.
Jesus Christ.
And is it blocking something shit now?
Oh my God,
we gotta get rid of it on this big
section or the pipes under there.
Holy Shit Man.
A Ui that is like the ultimate clogged
drain is so nasty,
but it is,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
No plungers get mad out.
Did I ever show you the picture of the
tree that was growing in my toilet pipe?
No tree.
No Dude.
I was having a problem.
My toilet wouldn't flush correctly,
so I had a fellow come over to take care
of it and he said,
dude,
he goes,
look at that.
That's an actual picture of the thing
that was in my bathroom.
What is it?
That is a tree that's roots got into a
small crack in the water pipe and they,
they,
they continue to grow where the pipe is,
crack it and once they crack it,
something goes inside and then it grows
where the water up the pipe.
So the pipe was clogged with like a
tree.
It looked like an animal.
Oh my God.
It's disgusting.
So for years you were,
you thought it was going that right out
of a pipe and it was.
Shows you what I'm eating is super
healthy.
You're literally shooting trees.
All the vitamins that come out.
My piss my pants is always a bright
orange.
It's the take so many vitamins.
It's the happiest route I ever saw.
It went hog wild.
It's like almost proof that what I'm
doing.
It's like little shop of horrors like
feed me Joe.
I don't think I was.
Yeah.
Wow.
I don't think I was eating wild game
back then.
Either one or what it would look like
now.
It was happier in the.
In your toilet that it was out in
nature.
What if you change your diet?
It turned different colors.
What if it's like it's only growing back
color because if you shit it didn't.
Maybe with like you're like a high beat
concentrate.
Die.
That's so big.
It looks like it has a personality
telling the rest of the trees.
Get in here bro.
I'm so happy.
Do you have a thought of nutrients?
There's water and shit done.
Love it.
Wait a minute.
In a pipe.
Yeah.
You live in a stew of water and shit and
they keep dropping shit on you every day
and you absorb it.
No way will you live there bro.
There's no dirt water and they let you
live.
No,
he has no idea on there,
bro.
I'm telling you.
Dirt sucks.
Fuck dirt when you need to do is grow in
a shit pipe.
Fuck Dude.
That sounds like shit.
Pipe pipe for a tree is like being Jz
with a cigar for a regular person.
Says,
oh,
so happy.
He found the ship pipe.
He's out there hustling.
He made his way up to shit.
Pipe.
You hear about Harry?
Yeah Bro.
He worked at that fucking pipe for
years,
man.
You got to admit the dude put his time
in.
Alright.
There's a lot of weeds out there that
are complaining about Harry,
but these fuckers,
they grow real fast and then they just
stay the same size.
They're not hustlers.
They don't have the long game like
Harry.
I don't know.
Harry seems happy,
but could he be the.
I mean I would miss the sun personally.
I'd missed the sunshine.
You say that.
Okay.
But Harry's mostly a route.
All right?
Could be out there in the dirt and
occasionally pick up a little good
point.
Was sad routes that have the story of
the two,
the rest of the root system.
Like they,
they're up above the rest of the roots.
Like,
what's going on up there?
Shut the fuck up.
I'm making a comment.
I'll make it a break for it.
Deer's can eat the little saplings.
Shut the fuck up.
Hi,
Ms Dot Harry.
Harry was a hustler.
Harry is the Jay Z of tree roots.
Do.
Did you hear how he got busted wide?
Yeah.
This plumber came in.
Oh,
you got an ambitious.
They ripped out.
I was telling him,
you gotta stay small.
You get too big.
You fucking salad keys day.
And that's when they come for you.
It's behind the music all over again.
Is that is?
That is terrible.
It is behind the music.
Goddammit.
You're right here.
We got too big.
I would.
Um,
he's a goddamn bad company.
Song.
He got playing there as when you see
what's going on around the world and
these horrible places.
Um,
my,
my daughters have friends and the sun in
the summer,
their parents take them to Haiti or
someplace and they work for a week or
two helping build these places and it's
not.
I was like,
Eh,
this is just like a white,
you know,
I'm feeling good about myself,
kind of a thing,
you know what I mean?
And then I go back home and the
wonderful people,
but they really do need the help.
Like they really honestly benefit from,
from people coming down and helping them
and bring supplies and stuff.
Do you have any desire to do that?
Like every pygmy guy,
I'd have to really think that one
through a man.
I think my best
method of helping is just talking shit.
Hear me about it.
Yeah,
you're good at it.
Yeah.
I mean donating money.
But I don't know,
but getting on camera and go sleeping on
A.
I don't know if that's the most
effective thing for me.
Yeah,
maybe that's just a cop out on my part.
I don't know.
I feel like I should do it
once.
You know what,
I think the real issue with all these
different places,
they don't like.
There's only so much access to growth in
certain places.
You know,
like we think of life as being growth
oriented,
like especially in this country,
in this country.
We think of life not as like,
do you have enough to eat?
Do you have friends around you that you
care about?
Are you having a good time?
We don't think about it that way.
We think about it as are you constantly
moving forward?
Are you out of the clubs now doing the,
the,
the no.
Good,
good,
good.
I heard you guys bought a new house
yammering.
Dora.
Yeah.
You're always moving.
You're moving up.
You're not always going.
Whereas that is just how we mark
success.
Whereas in a lot of cultures that's not
even a part of life.
There is no moving up.
Like you can get a job and you can work
and you were part of this community.
Do whatever you do,
whether you're a fisherman or whether
you're a carpenter,
whatever you do,
but that's it.
You just lived that life and so that's
their idea of what life is now.
Our idea of life is,
you know,
get a nice car,
get a nice house,
got a big TV,
but what if there's something past that,
right?
Like what if some new thing comes along
that makes this idea completely fucking
ridiculous?
No,
no,
no.
You get enough credit so you can plug
into the matrix and then we start
thinking like that.
Like with this idea that the only way
your life could ever be good if you get
a nice new laptop or get a,
you know,
or you live in a nice community.
You know,
that seems a little weird because really
it's just life.
No,
I know.
I mean the bigger.
Yeah,
and then you get,
you accumulate more liver.
The problem with it is that you
accumulate more things and then you,
you're still in that vulnerable feeling.
Now I got to pay for this and move
forward and get like you say,
get more then then you're with your
friend on his private jet and you're
like,
oh,
well I don't have that.
I guess I have to keep working.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
And then this guy has a yacht.
Oh my God.
It's got a yacht.
He's got a 59 foot yacht.
This is one big,
big,
like 100 hundred and 20 foot.
What's a good size yacht?
Connor put this up to their dad as he
pulled up behind him when he was like
hanging out wherever he is,
but that's a yacht.
I started thinking about the problems
you would have if you had this shot.
Like you got to have a security team
because someone's.
I'll show you how big it is.
So my God,
that looks like the death star.
It's got an opening on the side for a
boat.
The whole boat can go inside the yacht.
She cited problems you have to have.
If you had this shot,
could be even crazier.
Oh my looking.
Where is this space that is maybe
something like that.
Visa.
They say it.
They say a FIFA.
What is that?
That's silly.
Tell him to put a t h on that bitch.
Now there's A.
Yeah,
incredible man.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
but what's enough?
I guess is the thing,
man,
$360 million dollar yacht and he said,
Jesus Christ,
see what $360 million dollar yacht
fucking name,
man.
That's when you're seeing what are we
doing wrong that we don't see that
sitting back with a cigar so more
rutgers.
We've got to bring back record sales in
a way.
We looked at the books,
live concerts just can't do it.
It's just not enough money to charge
tickets.
I need $390 million to get a slightly
larger with a diamond encrusted anchor
and a crew that will
lower it and wipe it off where I pull
the water off when we pull it out of the
water crew of hot white chicks with big
asses.
It's only buddy who works there.
They don't hire any third world help.
Hot White chicks.
Do you think it's a sickness that we
have to keep racing or do you feel like
it's healthy?
I feel like it keeps you making stuff
and keeps you,
you know,
creating and doing things.
It can.
It can be either or.
Right.
I mean,
it can be a good thing because people
aren't ambitious and don't get things
done.
A lot of times we all know like lazy
guys and their sometimes their family
can suffer because they don't make ends
meet and it's not because of a lack of
opportunity because they fuck up and
they're lazy and they don't just gear
with it and get together,
but at a certain point in time we'd be
definitely know people that are caught
up in it to the point where that's all
they're concerned with,
they're concerned with is moving up and
the numbers and the ladder and the.
Yeah,
that's not good either.
So either one,
it's like you've defined this band,
comfortable balance as a human being and
don't get swept away by your pursuit.
Pursuit is just something that you're
engaging in.
But yeah,
this is why like I like to look at.
This is a fucking very hippy way to look
at things,
but I honestly like to look at all my
pursuits,
like everything I do or I try to do as
something that hopefully makes me a
better person is contradictory,
is a.
They are in some ways like Jujitsu,
a lot of people would think would be
contradictory to making you a better
person.
No,
you just have.
They're strangling people.
Show me the show.
It seems kind of mean Joe row.
That's not really what you're doing when
you're doing is you're testing yourself
in these extreme situations with other
likeminded people and he developed a
lot.
First of all,
you develop a keen understanding of your
actual vulnerability,
you know,
because I've been choked out by people
that are outweighed by like 30 pounds,
40 pounds,
strangling.
Yeah,
for sure man.
Yeah.
It happens all the time and I'm decent,
right?
Yeah.
And I get my ass kicked.
People way smarter than me.
It's humbling and people bigger than me
that are better than me.
They just run right through me like I
don't exist and I've been doing it a
long time.
So like
the average person that has this
delusional perspective of who they are,
you have to face and he also got to get
used to getting tapped out and getting
used to getting tapped out.
Like it's humbling and it doesn't feel
good.
And then you have to be able to just
accept it.
It's just a learning thing,
like don't get your ego attached to
this.
The reason why you got tapped out is
your arm is supposed to be here and you
reached here and you got caught.
So don't do that anymore.
Now you know should thank that person
for,
for taking advantage of whatever
possibilities you leave.
Because when you leave these openings,
now you need to know those openings are
there because you didn't know it was
there before.
Next time you won't do this with your
arm.
You'll keep your arm right here like
you're supposed to do that and you might
still get tapped out,
but it'll be harder.
Isn't it amazing?
Like any,
anytime you talk about whether it makes
you a good person,
any kind of a thing like that,
like what you're talking about is kind
of similar to yoga.
It's kind of similar to what you're
talking about,
like going and helping the pygmy.
It's all about the common denominator
with all of it is getting your ego out
of it,
getting your ego out of the way.
And it's a thing is looking at like
really taking some objective time.
Yeah.
A lot of people just keep going.
They don't ever stop and assess
themselves.
How could I have done that better?
How could I have handled this better?
Yeah,
it's,
there's a,
there's a real.
It's like if you can get rid of the,
the,
uh,
the ego and the self and all of us and
realize you're a part of something
larger.
Like even in Jujitsu,
like the way you're describing it,
it's that you're interacting with other
human beings.
It's not like you just isolated walking
around thinking I'm great.
It's only when you get there with other
people that you're kind of learning and
having that back and forth.
And I think,
um,
I honestly think yoga is real similar in
that way to yoga is very humbling when
you do it together with a group of
people and everyone's struggling,
oh,
and there's this brutal and that you're,
you're,
you're on the mat next to two tiny girls
who are just doing things that you can't
do.
And you're just like,
that's,
it's humbling.
It's humbling.
Super humbling.
There's a lady that works out in my yoga
class sometimes she's like in her,
maybe
she might be 60 and she's definitely in
her late fifties and she's jacked dude.
She's Jackie.
She does handstands and shit.
It's like it's so inspirational.
Amazing.
Watching this lady take a yoga class.
I mean she does crossfit and she's just
fucking completely shredded six pack
shoulders,
just obviously fantastic genetics,
but also never stopped working out or
whole life.
Always moving,
always doing it.
Jesus like it to be next to this lady
was also of course ultra flexible in a
class.
Watch her do all this.
She was like,
Holy Shit,
you're arms are shaking like a little
baby giraffe for her.
It's humbling though.
That's my point is that like it's
fucking hard.
Yeah.
When you do hard shit and I don't think
enough of us do hard shit.
Puts things in perspective.
Your mind wants to gravitate towards
softness and the couch and the easy road
and naps and Ah,
fuck that.
Let's quit.
Yeah,
your mind gravitates towards that easy.
Oh,
100 percent.
Just like,
oh,
someone's gave me a someone's and you
know why people wallow in shit because
it's warm and comfortable.
They're great.
It is great.
It was great.
It is.
It's like,
oh,
it's just like this,
but you know,
there's that thing like we're talking
about,
you know,
being,
living in these communities and other
countries and you just,
you're a fisherman,
you do your little thing.
Is that wallowing and shit and just
things small or is there a beauty and a
great life living in something small
like that.
There's beauty and a great life and
doing things that make you happy.
There's a lot of people that believe
that subsistence living,
like those folks that live off the land,
like in villages and they catch fish and
they have like a whole setup and then
not without food they have food,
but the life essentially is about
procuring food.
It's not about getting a job at a
factory somewhere.
Right?
Right.
And then the factory will come along and
then all of a sudden the factory says,
Hey,
we'll pay you $2 a day.
Like,
Holy Shit,
I've never seen $2 in my life,
and you started working for this factory
and now you're eating terrible food.
You're not having it hanging out in the
village.
You're working all day.
You're making whatever fucking brand of
sneakers that they sell in America
because they can make them down there
and pay a guy $2 a day or whatever the
rate is.
I'm obviously exaggerating,
but I don't think I'm exaggerating,
but much like two bucks an hour maybe
$16 day.
Whoa.
You fucking really taking care of your
guys,
right?
We're good ma'am.
Ship Shit down there to have it taken
care of and that these people without us
would be broke.
What?
Well,
okay.
Maybe they would.
Or maybe they live in a rich eco
environment right now.
Rich,
maybe they live in like a nice simple
will.
Healthy world.
Maybe they live in a.
You ever seen that fucking were to
Herzog?
Documentary.
Happy People know it's called happy
people or something in the taiga life in
the taiga.
It's about the Tiger River and Siberia
and these people that live up there and
they have almost no money.
Everything,
whatever money that they do have,
like if they trap furs and stuff like
that,
they'll trade it in for like equipment
and some money to get supplies and they
live off the land.
Everything is living off the land and
they're like the fucking happiest people
in the world.
Really.
It's weird man.
It's a super weird documentary and it
really makes you confront like what is
life about?
Yeah.
And then also the way these two
questions,
right?
Like are they happy because we evolved
that way and that those motions of going
out and catching fish and hunting and
growing your own vegetables and having a
tight knit small community is the
benefit in that is that it hits all the
old notes that we've had since we
evolved,
you know,
from the time we were lower primates to
living in these small clusters of monkey
people living in villages to working
together and living off the land and
then that has been going on for so long.
Yeah.
Your DNA knows it.
This most recent trend of moving towards
some sort of a technological world is so
uncomfortable for us and is working in
cubicles with fluorescent lighting is so
new.
Yeah,
no,
it's.
It's.
It's unhealthy.
It.
My sister runs this little nonprofit in
New Jersey called city green and she
takes these cities like passaic and
Patterson,
these places that were booming and now
they've kind of fallen off and she
creates these city gardens in all of
these different places and bring young
students in to sit and work with the
earth and grow vegetables.
The change in these kids who are just on
their phones and just in this tough city
world and there's no money and it's like
this desperate.
You don't know.
There's no sense of place.
There's no sense of what you're supposed
to do.
They sit in garden and actually smell
the dirt and harvest vegetables and cook
that food.
It changes their life because just what
you're saying,
it's what we're supposed to do.
It's our nature as beasts.
What we're supposed to do.
As much as I'm saying it's what we did
do for so long that we know it and the
groups have already been cut almost like
what we're doing now is like you ever
tried to take a screwdriver and a
screwdriver doesn't quite fit the screw,
but you can kind of make it work and
when you kind of make it work,
it kind of chews up the screw a little
bit because every time I use a
screwdriver,
that's a human being in a city,
right slot right in.
Now think a human being that's living in
the taiga.
You're talking about groups that had
been polished and cut an exact fit for
the environment.
Boom.
So all their human reward systems for
survival are.
They're not based on some sort of
technological innovation that will move
us towards a world of artificial
intelligence and fucking the Internet
going through your brain pumping through
the sky and Wifi all over the world.
Not that their grooves or carved
differently than ours.
Right?
So are good.
So don't you think your groove,
like when you go out into the woods,
don't you feel
terrified shouldn't be there?
What am I doing?
But when you come,
so when you come home and you survived
you,
your soul,
something's happened to your soul.
Yeah.
I appreciate civilization.
See,
it's not.
It's not an either or is my point.
It's not like,
well,
you got to live in the woods.
That's the only way,
man.
You got to be one with nature.
Okay.
Well,
you also should go to a nice restaurant
in a city.
You'll see a comedy show.
I mean,
the very thing that we enjoy most
watching and performing,
standup comedy is all done with electric
lights.
Shure microphone in a completely
unnatural environment.
That's air conditioned.
Yeah,
but you're dealing with human beings.
You're dealing with heartbeats and
sweat.
Sure breath,
but you need all this technology and
this is a totally new thing,
but it's most important thing to us,
right?
This is a new endeavor for humans.
Yeah,
but don't you feel like if you're
totally disconnected from nature and you
just live in that city,
I know people that don't leave
Manhattan,
that's not good.
They're not healthy people.
Yeah.
That's not good.
No,
they're.
They're like shaky and weird.
Next to the battery all the time.
That is not good.
The biggest Condo,
I'm telling you.
One walk,
one hike,
and it was we would fix their head or
you can see the.
Here's the thing.
I think you can be completely healthy.
Being some fucking business person
that's out there kicking ass and taking
names.
I don't think it's impossible.
Not Possible.
I think every time for me to say that
someone can't do it and be like as
fulfilled and happy as these people in
the Werner Herzog documentary.
Huh?
It's ridiculous.
Like what?
What do I know?
People are so different.
They vary so much and I know people that
are fucking miserable when you take them
in the woods,
all this.
Especially people who don't exercise at
all.
Have you ever seen him about a guy that
doesn't exercise at all?
Trying to make it up a big steep hill?
It is.
Oh yeah.
It's hilarious.
Feet started hurting.
Her ankles pop like they're basically
like sticks around and buy bags of
Jello.
It really gets going and then they have
to move their body up a hill.
Fuck.
We had a.
We live on a hill and they were paving
it the other day and my office looks out
over the,
over the street,
you know,
and I watched people walk their dogs or
run,
that's why I texted you about hills,
which we can talk about later.
And uh,
I,
so they're paving the streets so
everyone had to park down at the bottom
of the street so everyone had to walk to
their cars and I never saw these people.
They were coming out like,
which is like stick people walking and
then having to go back up the hill.
Miserable.
They don't walk,
they never walk in and they're like
trying to like get up a thing,
like a,
like a broken down robot.
Yeah.
It's,
I mean some people were injured for
sure,
but some people they just stopped using
it and it started deteriorating.
And you know,
you tribute that to getting older,
which is absolutely a factor,
but it's more of a factor when you don't
exercise.
And it sounds like some Goddamn
infomercial.
I know I do,
but I'm,
I'm being honest like everybody,
I'm not talking about do the shit that
you know you do.
You or anybody that's like fucking
crossfit and like that lady in my yoga
class who looks like a Greek statue.
No,
you don't have to go completely nuts,
but you got to move.
You got to do something for your body.
Got To do.
Just go walk man.
Walk up hills if you can.
If you live in a place that has hills,
it's fucking giant for you and don't for
Chrysler.
Don't think you're really running when
you're running on a treadmill.
Motherfucker.
I was running yesterday.
I was thinking about that because I just
listened to it.
He runs Cleveland,
but just giving them our time,
telling me he was running like seven
minute miles.
My bitch.
You weren't going anywhere.
You're in the same room and that is a
crazy thing to say.
Yeah,
exactly.
And getting off and writing seven minute
miles on a fucking treadmill.
You're in the same room.
I want to hear any of this mild talk.
This is crazy.
And get outside with the sun in your
face and the wind blowing on you fucking
elliptical.
Told me the other day.
I went five miles.
I'm like,
how did I go five miles isn't even a
method of transportation if,
if I got off this thing walking around
this way,
at least when you're on a treadmill,
you're mimicking running.
Yeah,
exactly.
You're kind of running the with the
thing you are,
but it's like 60 percent,
maybe 70,
70 percent running.
Yeah,
running is.
It's better than nothing.
Elliptical is what is that?
Yeah.
You're pulling.
I'm pulling out my going miles by
pulling.
I didn't understand what you were saying
about when you texted me that you do the
hills for an hour.
What does that mean though?
I mean an hour and that's how long the
run takes.
Takes it outside for an hour.
But you go,
what time I start.
This is my.
I tried,
I've gone further and shorter and I'll
still go shorter if I'm short on time
because the end part of my run that I've
been doing pretty regularly is the last
part is a mile and seven tenths of that
is straight up and it's fucking rough.
Yeah,
I can.
If I could get up it away with a really
slow,
steady pace,
but I'm way to meet head for that so I
do mad sprints until I can't do this
anymore.
And then I paused and I try to get that
pause down to a minute,
pause down to a minute where my
heartbeat gets to below 1:40
beats a second and then I charge,
so I have spots where I know that I can
reach.
Then I try to go to 20 yards past that
spot to go 20 yards,
but the ultimate goal is I'll never
really make it.
The ultimate goal is to be able to
sprint all the way up the hill.
Gotcha.
To sprint all.
I have this killer hill,
not the one I was just talking about
going up the other way.
It's a killer hill paved,
but it's killer and uh,
I was thinking I should do because I'll
go run three miles,
but um,
you know,
it's a little hilly,
but,
but I was thinking like if I were to
just spend the workout going up and down
that hill,
it's amazing,
but like,
I don't know what would be,
what would constitute too much
comparable or more than the three miles
that I'm running.
It'll be way harder.
It'll be harder,
but would do it three times or I would
say do it once and see how you feel and
maybe don't even do it that hard.
You know,
that I've heard that advice.
I'm a fucking terrible listener to my
own advice because I always do too much
and then get real sore and then I
realize,
okay,
I got to back this off and build up to
it.
That that was a big thing with me with
the running.
I'm like,
I tried to go way hard on it real quick
and also tried to go way hard on with
those five finger shoes.
I'm going to be super careful with those
things.
Yeah,
there's great benefit in those things,
but you think they lost the class action
lawsuit,
and I should clear this up for a lot of
people that have been texting
me about this or I'm messaging me or
commenting on my instagram posts about
those things I learned.
First of all,
I don't.
I'm not paid by these people.
They don't support me in any way.
There's no.
They never spent a dime on advertising
or penny advertising this podcast.
This is vibram vibram five fivefingers
shoes.
I learned about them from and I learned
about them before monkey.
But mark,
yeah,
those five finger toasters.
But Mark Sisson,
who is this,
he's a very well respected,
um,
endurance athlete.
He was coach and now he does.
Um,
he brought this book,
the primal blueprint about like healthy
diets and he goes back and forth from
Quito or to like a real,
real low sugar,
low carb,
very fat adapted,
really very smart and very,
very well educated.
What's his name again?
Mark Sisson says,
and he was talking about these things,
but that's the only things you.
Whereas most times he's barefoot and
he's essentially.
Yeah,
he's essentially saying that your feet
are in shoes.
It's like your feet being in a cast and
all those muscles in your feet sort of
atrophy and then when you put on those
five finger shoes,
those muscles have to work in a way that
really don't have to work when they're
in a shoe.
It's much harder for them.
So the same exercise that you would do
the same run is way harder because your
feet are getting away.
Harder workout,
but you have to be careful because if
you go too hard,
a lot of people get plantar fasciitis,
which is a really bad like pain.
Pain in the bottom of their foot with
the Fascia is all fucked up and it's
tearing and the bottom of your foot is
in severe agony.
I know several people that have got it,
got it.
From wearing those five finger or toe
shoes on a treadmill,
kneel daily and he's light.
He's not even pushing mass.
He is,
but neil is a bit of an obsessive person
like in a good way and I think that
maybe he got obsessed with running and
maybe ran a little too hard.
Shoes.
You've got to be super careful though.
She was milled up slow,
but once you do build up you can.
You could run in those things and like
my feet feel so different than they felt
like five months ago.
Really?
Yeah,
they're way different.
The way stronger.
Way Stronger.
Do you need strong feet?
Well,
here's where it's good.
When are you doing with these feet?
Just walking around.
It's easier.
Yeah.
My ankles are stronger.
My feet because I'm running all this
weird fucked up terrain.
Libyans when you get up at night to go
to the bathroom where you wake up in the
morning,
I gotta get up and my ankles are like
waking up kind of a thing.
Do you still have that?
No,
I don't have any of that.
You don't have any of that?
Did you before you ran in these shoes?
No,
not really.
I've never really had much ankle pain.
If a temporary just like creaky.
No.
Like beer cans,
ankle now for whatever reason,
I never had that.
I did so much of my youth kicking.
Things like my ankles are pretty strong.
Right?
Because there's so much.
Because when you're throwing kicks like
you think about especially like a side
kick or a front kick,
there is so much pressure on the ankle.
You're.
Yeah,
you're using them not so much with round
kicks,
round kicks.
Kind of pull it apart.
You hit with the Shin,
but when you're hitting with the actual
foot itself,
there's a lot of stress on the ankle and
I think my ankles develop really strong
because of that.
So when I run I feel a big difference in
the workout when I run up a straight
hill versus a run up like a trail with
rocks and shit where I have to jump from
one step stone to another and I'm
navigating your way with me.
Come,
come do it with me one time.
I'll do it.
Yeah.
Don't do it with the five finger shoes.
Doing regular shoes and I still
alternate when I need a really hard
workout.
I alternate like and then I put these on
is this is what I like the best.
He's Solomon trail shoes.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You know why?
Because this,
this tread here is the shit shreds slide
out.
Oh,
not at all.
It's like a,
like a dirt bike tire or something.
It just grips in the dirt.
It's like the best traction.
How far?
Like A,
like a flat run.
Do you go?
I don't ever flat rate.
Don't ever fly.
Me and I run are always going up in
these trips.
These little.
Yeah,
because it's exciting.
It's so much more fun when you're in a
trail post to go back to nature.
By the way,
you can get excited when you're out
there.
I see a person occasionally walking
their dog,
hanging out,
walking the trails and shit.
Now that's great,
but it's mostly just me running these
hard ass hills is nothing more fun when
you're sprinting.
When that was a kid we walked to school
through the woods.
Oh Man.
It was just when you would take off and
you're jumping from rock to rock,
you know,
especially when you know the trail and
you know where are.
You've got to jump in slide.
Yeah,
you're playing.
that's exactly it.
You're planning now.
When I run to it,
you don't want to do that.
When I ran for real,
when first you can have a four year run,
that's then I'd be.
Then I'd start thinking I'm having a
heart attack.
A heart attack.
Your heart is working hard to bring it
in.
Go for them.
Yeah,
man.
First of all,
there's been proof that a lot of
endurance athletes find great benefit in
marijuana.
What?
Even smoking?
Vaping.
It in particular.
Some of them edibles.
Yeah.
They feel like it dilates your lungs.
Make sure lungs take in more oxygen,
rear.
It also makes you more in tune with your
body.
A lot of weight lifter smoke weed before
they lift weights.
Really lot of weightlifters more and
more now than ever before.
I get messages from people all the time
that say,
dude,
I,
you know,
I thought it was a loser.
Like people say,
I was a loser for smoking pot before I
worked out,
but at some of my best workouts ever,
I'm not talking about gets so blitzed
where you like,
you look at the curl,
like,
how do I know how to move my arm like
this?
I feel weird.
Get just a little high.
We just a hill.
Your muscles like yoga to like Terence
Mckenna actually believed that yoga was
a guide to how to use Hash.
He felt like has sheesh and um,
and marijuana,
you know how she says made from
marijuana?
Yeah.
That's.
Hashish is awesome.
And people.
But your sash sounds like you're doing
heroin,
like to dine,
educated uninitiated.
It's just super strong
DHC,
right?
Yeah.
But the,
uh,
the,
the feeling that they would get from it
is from Yoga,
doing it that way is what inspired those
moves.
And he believes that yoga started with
people that were smoking hash.
He believes that that's where it
originated from.
Like when you're high and you start
stretching,
it feels really good.
And these people are known torris users
of cannabis and how she and a lot of
smoke,
like he was saying,
the dirty secret amongst dues.
Is that really what they're concentrated
on is how many chillums can you smoke
and still be there.
Like they,
they'll like take pride in chillum is
like a head of Hash.
Oh,
that's a call.
The chillum yeah.
What is the exact definition of Chelan?
Because the only people I've ever heard
is hash people talk about it and I don't
see him chill them find that because I'm
not A.
I've only smoked hash couple of times.
Not like a prolific hash user,
but in other countries there's serious
ha.
It's weird because like people get
busted and they get treated when they
get busted with Hash.
Like they're smuggling meth or
something.
So yeah,
it sounds more intense.
It sounds like a different thing.
It's not a dangerous thing.
This is the point.
It's not at all.
No,
but it gets classified in those ways.
Like people think of Hash as like
something from.
Wasn't that what they got arrested for
in the midnight express?
That's right.
That's right,
yeah.
We'd,
yeah,
right,
exactly.
Turkish prison for weed.
Yeah.
Here's this dude going to chill him.
Oh boy.
Yeah.
So that guy,
that guy,
that guy gets high as fuck.
These guys are so high.
They're painting themselves up like
superheroes and shit.
He's all dreadlocked.
He's his face.
Looks like a ghost.
So these are sod dudes that are smoking
chillums.
Crazy beard.
Do you see the Hash there in his pipe?
So Saad dues just get barbecued barbecue
high and they do yoga and I noticed it.
What it is.
Yeah,
when I,
I,
this was before I was like doing yoga
regularly,
but I had to do this show and I was
particularly nervous because someone I
really didn't like was in the audience
and really did.
I'm like Yay.
I really didn't like was in the audience
and some people that were there to see
me with were in the audience.
So it was your night?
Yeah,
it was weird.
Right?
So what I did was I smoked weed and I
got really stretchy and I started
stretching out and in my stretching in
like this,
like severe stretching is going to sound
super fucking Hippie,
but I,
I felt a severe sense of forgiveness for
this person that I don't like and I
still don't like him to this day.
Yeah.
I do avoid him at all costs.
It's not a,
it's not a healthy human,
but I felt a severe sense of forgiveness
and acceptance and almost like,
like pity.
Yeah,
no,
that's no,
that's real.
That's not a hand.
Love to have this weird love thing.
I feel bad for the guy.
Like I'm almost like I don't want him in
my life because I don't want to manage
it.
Right.
I know what you mean.
But there's yoga does.
When you go into Yoga,
you can be stressed and balled up and
you can have like a work thing rattling
in your head that's just.
And you could be pissed at somebody when
you come out,
it doesn't matter.
And is the thing that seems
counterintuitive.
Like why would stretching make your mind
feel better?
Like what is going on?
And there's.
So there's all this rationalization,
right?
Is it,
um,
endorphins that are being released?
Is it the,
is it just the fact that your body
needed to exercise?
But that's,
that's this sort of weird sort of,
um,
need to dissect things and figure out
the one cause yeah,
the one reason,
a minimalist approach or minimalizing
yeah,
you want to,
you want to understand it,
you want to get your head around it.
It's all those things.
It's the physical thing.
It's probably the endorphins.
It's the physical release of the muscles
which relaxes your body,
which relaxes your mind because
everything's connected.
And it's also the act of stretching this
intense act of stretching and holding
positions.
It does something for the overall way
that your mind interacts with your body
completely.
The time body affects the way your mind,
where time becomes different in a class
like that.
It goes by super quick and slow.
My 90 minute class,
my yoga teacher said,
uh,
she said,
at the end of class she said,
it's yoga is like aspirin.
You may not exactly know why it works,
but you know,
it works and it's the yoga.
You don't know what exactly just
happened during this hour,
but I feel much more at peace when I
walk out of there.
Then I did coming in.
Yeah,
man,
a hundred percent.
That's a good way to look at it.
Yeah,
it just works.
So if,
uh,
they talk crazy.
Shouldn't yoga though?
No,
this is massaging your descending colon.
it's not.
You can only use 70 percent of your
brain.
No,
that's not true.
That's been disproven.
Yeah.
No,
I,
it took me a long time to find a yoga
teacher that wasn't taking me down the
uh,
the,
in the weird spots and talking all that
stuff.
She's just.
So let's just do this.
Here's the Po's correct your arm.
Correct.
That she doesn't get hippy dippy one ohm
and you're in.
It's just awesome enough as it is and
it's on all of them that do this.
You know,
the place I go to,
the trigger runs it.
She never does it.
She doesn't say crazy shit,
but she's inspirational and there's a
lot of people in there that are
inspirational and all,
all their weird styles.
Like this one dude that teaches my class
college freaky tattoos get this weird
style.
Oh yeah.
You know,
this other guy is like a boxing fan and
teaches a killer yoga class.
It's a,
it's a weird thing,
man.
There's mutations of it and like,
you know,
people start to make it into the sport
and do all this stuff.
People get a little fired up with that,
right?
Not really into that.
You know,
what I don't like is the,
uh,
the dude that takes the shirt off,
the big sweaty older dude that takes his
shirt off.
I mean,
it's 90 percent women.
I just feel like sit in the back,
calm down.
Don't make a scene just as a dude do
your thing and get out of there.
What do you mean?
He's,
he's got a great gross ponytail and he
takes his shirt off and take their shirt
off.
Let's keep their shirt on in your place.
I keep my shirt on.
C,
no one in my place.
Keeps her shirt on.
No guys,
no.
Yeah,
maybe like one out of 10 I'm sweating so
I'm sweating like an animal.
One hundred and five degrees in there.
I don't agree.
Why would you want a shirt on?
I don't do the hot yoga.
I don't do bikram.
Straight Straight Yoga and I'm straight
and you say this should I do is gay.
I don't do your gay yoga.
What's.
You know,
I'm so sweaty.
Even doing that.
The I have to keep the shirt on.
My Mat will be so liberal.
It's disgust.
Scared.
Don't be scared of us.
Matt there to work out here to sweat.
Now I.
You know what I'm scared of?
I'm scared of.
I don't want to offend that little girl
who's next to me.
Well,
she's in Yoga class,
man.
I know,
but I just feel like.
Do you need me with Harry back next to
you?
That's you.
Being a comedian is he'll look at me
grabbing my clothes on me that I'm sure
you're probably thinking of material.
You find me disgusting.
I find me just goes,
go.
I want to look at myself in the mirror.
Exactly.
It's supposed to be about the act of the
movements.
I know.
When can you do the movements most free
for you?
If it's with a shirt on a shirt,
I feel like out of kindness I just keep
my shirt on and keep a low profile.
Do you tie around the base of your Dick
and balls?
So everybody's yoga pants or like a
board shorts,
title,
same shirts that I run in.
I dress up like a high school gym coach,
sweatpants,
Oldschool,
gray style all the way down there going
to be so hot,
hot sweatpants and a and a b class man.
I should do that one day just to see if
I can dress like a recipe.
Like a real thick.
Yeah.
Cutting weight to the worst if you will.
Those like thick ass old school,
you know who's making those.
Again,
converse.
Converse is making up fake ass old
school,
gray sweatshirt,
back that don't have any markings on
them.
Interesting.
And they're really high quality.
I was like,
Ooh,
this is like old school minimalist.
Yeah,
I like that.
Look.
I would do that.
And you're like,
oh,
you're crazy.
Colors and stripes and shit.
Gray sweat shirt,
turn,
color,
pop up doing.
If you weren't a black shirt,
no one knows if you're sweating.
I had to get real close to you.
I sweat like a man.
I'm sweating now.
I've mean the yoga class,
I'm going to be sweating like crazy hard
work.
It is.
I love it.
But get high and do it.
Just try it.
I will.
I don't know.
Right.
I'm going to try it or he'll yell at me
depending on how much pot smoke.
Joe.
I started and I started.
My heart was racing.
I started thinking was having a heart
attack.
You know what?
You need to spray the spray here.
Jamie.
Oh,
I did.
Yeah,
I gave it to the shops.
I'm here,
but I think.
Well I'll get some more with me.
I was going to bring you bread today
because I made this olive Sweden Walnut
bread and then uh,
I forgot.
Do you ever make spicy bread?
No.
Crushed red pepper.
Anything in it?
No.
Is that what you like?
I've had a pretty good like Cheddar,
crushed red pepper.
There's a couple of good bread places in
Ohio where I'm from.
Oh,
really?
Explore that.
A good pie place.
That makes a good pot pie.
Pot Pie.
You don't.
You don't see a lot of pot pies and
yeah.
You know that kind.
There's a place in Burbank that does it.
Reiki outer crust,
the cubes or chicken with that sort of
yellow broth with the carrots and celery
in there and like woo.
It's like Thanksgiving and a cup of
peas.
Peas,
Goddamn a pot pie.
I'm spacing on the name,
but there's a place in Burbank and does
it.
Five pot pies to die for pis at damn
delicious meal.
It really is.
It makes you so warm inside.
It's like the ultimate comfort food.
It really is.
It might be right,
but you that in a really good meatloaf
with mashed potatoes and gravy.
Oh my God.
I have to fuck with that too.
Oh,
that's nice.
That's a slightly different dough.
Put both of those little more butter in
that dope.
It's no extra.
When you make the dough for a pot pie,
you're using like a whole stick of
butter.
That's what you're talking about.
That's why it's so God damn good.
So good.
I wish they could make cows like
engineered cow.
If they they get to this crispr thing,
you know,
just please make some cows that don't
have a head.
Just make some cow and the top of its
neck is a computer so we don't have to
think about cruelty.
Yeah,
there's no consciousness whatsoever.
And just make me a nice butter.
Grass fed butter.
Headless.
It would be so much nicer.
Open up its neck and just put grass down
there,
grind the grass up and then pushed it
and be like a fireplace and you can put
a neck hole.
You get the butter out the other end so
it doesn't look so nice.
No suffering.
How about I don't even have a shape.
Like a cow if you tripping on that.
Yeah.
How about a ball of meat that gives you
butter?
It's coming.
I bet you it's coming,
but just giant bag of tits.
That's all you need is like the other,
the computers take care of all the other
stuff.
Yeah,
right.
Just to just to just a warehouse filled
with tits on a rack.
Yeah,
just like they,
they engineer of a frame of bones that
shaped like a basket and in that basket
is like an inner crust.
It's like a pot pie crust.
The meat which is the crust of the pot
pie and then the inside is all tit
heavy.
So delightful.
No guilt milk out of that fucker all day
long and it's phenomenal and it just,
it just exists on a substrate of ground
up grass.
Say you
have ground up grass all around the
meat.
Outer Shell.
Sort of like the aluminum amount of pot
pie.
You know you have that aluminum foil
around the edge.
Yeah.
Would be delightful if somebody gives
you a pot pie without the aluminum foil
around the edge,
they can go fuck them.
So I'm like,
God,
what are they animals,
Monster.
Good Lord.
Where did you grow up?
I can't even dig my fork underneath.
Scoop out the dry,
under size with the gravy on top.
That little treat at the end of this,
the bass,
the bass crest basis,
moist crossed the moistness crust,
right?
The past is you have a little bit of the
top crust to the crunchy outside the
ring.
Let's get outta here.
Now you can get a room and just sort of
pot pies and one of those rooms with
that giant per day with the three hoses.
We're going to need it after this
pile.
This fucking carbs here.
When are we going to Musso and frank's?
Oh yeah.
We're gonna.
Keep talking about.
We do keep doing that.
We should do that before a set at the
store one night.
Yeah.
Let's do that as the move.
Like gentlemen?
Yeah.
Should we wear suits?
Yes.
One hundred percent.
Kind of a lighter please.
I have a suit.
No,
you do.
You to get a suit for a school function
for my kid.
Oh really?
What do you mean?
What kind of question one?
I always have one,
um,
that I,
uh,
were for the UFC,
but the UFC one stays at the EOC so that
I don't have to do anything.
I just go there.
That's smart.
I like a nice suit.
He just looked good.
Do you wear pocket squares?
Always look good now.
When I hosted this TV show I did.
Yeah.
He was always a pocket square.
Yeah,
they made me.
They forced that useless piece of cloth.
Right.
There is a funny know when you need a
tourniquet.
It was a little pocket square and a
Madonna came in to do the show and uh,
the whole building was like electric.
It was like Madonna is coming and it
really was like energy,
like you could feel energy in the
building because Madonna was walking in.
Did you call her Madonna?
So I came in.
Yeah.
And I was like,
I got to go meet her before the show or
I'm going to be too freaked out.
So I just walked into the dressing room
and I'm like,
Hi Madonna.
I'm Tom.
She's like,
nice to see you.
And she walks up.
She goes,
this has got to go
with the pocket square out.
And like I said,
I'm not wearing it.
Guy Ritchie,
her ex husband is a proponent of the
pocket square guy.
Richie was on my podcast talking about
the importance of the suit and having a
square.
Hilarious because she immediately.
I just met her two seconds.
He whipped it out of my and tossed it
there.
She was at a young Tom pop
face.
Son of a bitch.
Yeah.
Look at that,
Mr.
I'll steal your girl with your fucking
do.
I read a lot different now.
Barbershop different.
Do I look from that shot?
There'll be honest or what we are.
We went to Delhi.
You gained a couple pounds here.
You're making delicious bread.
I am.
Did a Ricky Gervais' laugh hard at
everything.
This is move removed.
Seems like a jolly fellow.
Especially when Jerry said it.
A good move.
Yeah.
Always make Jordan
say it louder.
Something about English people,
right?
Guy Ritchie was describing with his
English accent.
The suit.
I was all in.
Damn it.
Where I stopped those at the pocket
square.
I might die.
Motherfucker not wearing a tie.
That was the other thing.
He was talking about ties.
I'm like,
dude,
no tie.
Kill somebody with a tie.
Grab a hold of somebody with a tie.
You can kill them.
You,
your,
your broad,
you've got broad shoulders.
It's like you skinny guys,
skinny English dudes with a tie.
It's a different thing.
Well,
the problem with me is that some people
have choked me too many times.
I see you.
Have.
You feel like someone's getting that
Hedburg joke.
I've been choked hundreds of times.
Literally the average person has been
choked with the average person in the
street.
If they get choked with once or twice in
their life.
Yet what the fuck happened?
And the journey from white belt to black
belt.
I was choked for sure.
Hundreds of times.
Oh my God.
No idea.
How many really bad at you asked me how
many times I have to tap out because
someone was choking me.
I'd be like,
Shit.
Hundreds.
Hundreds of times for sure.
It has to be.
Especially in the early days,
my game,
I got choked all the time.
All the time.
That's not pleasant.
Get choked five slash six times by one
guy.
Oh God.
Before I moved to the next guy.
It's crazy.
So I'm not wearing a fucking.
No,
not doing that,
but I remember how that works.
I'm choking myself,
grabs you.
If you had to do Jujitsu with a tie,
that's all anybody would go for the
truth.
Of course everybody had to wear a tie
and instead of wearing a belt,
everybody has to wear a tie or you can
take the belt and wrap it around the
dude's neck.
Save.
You started with the black belt tied
around your neck,
right?
Nobody would go for anything other than
the belt.
Get a hand under that belt,
grab it and twist and you're out cold.
I have to do a secure,
secure some part of your body weight and
keep you from moving in.
Maybe like a side mount or a crucifix
position where I have trapping arm
trapped the other arm with my neck and
I'm going to choke the shit out of you.
This isn't happening at your daughter's
school function,
but I think it should be.
Grab someone's belt and knock him if.
No,
no.
If someone had a belt around her neck
like around the neck,
you guys Jitsu.
Guys were rolling around.
The ultimate goal would be to get the
belt around the guy's neck,
like if you could do that,
that would be the number one thing to
do.
And if you already had it,
like nodded around your neck,
like that was how you started,
were you not around your waist?
Right.
Keep people would kill each other.
Immediately.
Grabbed that rope around your neck and
it.
That'd be the ultimate goal.
Forget foot locks.
Fuck your foot lock.
Like you've done all the work for me.
Yeah.
I'm going to grab that rope around your
neck and put you to sleep.
This is crazy because all you'd have to
do is twist it.
You can tell.
I like I had a choke
my dog out once.
That way.
Dog was attacking a cat and I got my
hand inside his collar and I put them
asleep.
Really?
Yeah.
You just grabbed.
I grabbed his collar and I twisted it
down and cranked it.
I did you Jitsu on my dog.
Put them right here.
Knocked them out instantly.
Instantly.
Yeah.
Just like it does a person resisting.
He didn't know what was going on,
so I got it in there,
grabbed a of where the buckle is.
I just think I stepped over him and
cranked on it.
He just went limp when cat took off.
I'm going to try that dude.
It works.
That shouldn't do it to dogs,
but I mean,
but that's a person too.
It's the idea is the arteries around
your neck that feed your brain.
You shut those off like a garden hose.
Think like you.
You fold the garden hose and then the
water stops falling.
That's what happens to your brain and
then you go out.
That's why it's not nearly as dangerous
as a knockout people's.
It's just flow.
People get confused about that.
Like they think that a concussion and
being choked out.
It's the same thing.
Still giving me your brain damage,
bro.
It's not.
It's not going to your brain damage.
It happens.
People in class,
they go right back to rolling.
They don't have no ill effects at all.
Really?
Yeah.
You just go to sleep back to it.
You wake up and you're like,
what happened?
Like you don't even realize it.
Like what happened?
He's like,
Oh shit.
That I get choked out and everybody
starts laughing because that happens in
Jujitsu class people.
As long as you're fine,
people will start laughing because it
happens to everybody.
Yeah,
for sure.
If you don't tap,
you go to sleep.
Everybody does.
It sounds fun.
It is fun,
honestly.
Yeah.
Till girl does it to super humiliating.
Right?
When's the last time you were choked out
by a girl or a guy?
Anybody?
Uh,
John Jacques Machado tapped me like a
few months back.
Oh yeah.
But he always Ken.
Yeah.
I don't think it was a joke.
It was an arm bar when you rolled with
someone who's really good,
you're going to get caught.
Yeah.
Just.
No,
no way around it.
Right?
You want a girl doesn't deal.
Duncan was taking some classes at CIC.
Kept choking him out.
It doesn't get,
I'm going to work on this.
Some people just don't get into it,
you know?
But for people who don't get into it,
I get it.
Just get into something else that's hard
to just get into something that's hard
to do.
Would you get high into Jujitsu?
Oh yeah.
Everybody does.
Oh really?
Oh yeah.
Super popular.
Makes you better.
Really.
One hundred percent.
Why?
I think you're more conscious of it.
More focused on what you're doing.
It it.
It provides a type of focus and you
don't.
It doesn't seem as here's the thing,
the type of consciousness that you have
when you are rolling with person,
a person in Jujitsu,
when someone's trying to get you and
you're trying to defend yourself,
that type of feeling that you get is
very different than any feeling that you
get in most of life other than an actual
conflict with the person,
which is pretty rare.
Luckily we have a nice society,
right?
Yeah.
If you live in a nice neighborhood,
but that feeling for whatever reason
lends itself very well to getting high
because when you get high you get into
this sort of like not me state,
like an ego dropped off state.
That's one of the reasons why people get
so vulnerable.
They feel vulnerable because they feel
like they don't.
They don't have that ego anymore.
It's a very ego diminishing subs.
It's like a almost like a medicine for
diminishing the ego.
Obviously the effects are different on
different people,
but that on top of the focus aspect of
it makes it really attractive to people
who do Jujitsu because you can let go of
the bullshit.
You not all tense and then you could
focus on what you're actually trying to
do and it doesn't get in the way.
You see things better.
He thinks you feel things better.
You're more cognizant of how your body
works and some people say that that's a
cop out and that really you should just
get more comfortable with your body
period and they're probably right.
It's probably something to that too,
but is there any elements like when you
get high where you're just like,
it's all cool.
It doesn't matter because you need.
You need an edge to go fight fighting
because you're not hitting each other.
Right,
and I mean I think it's more of A.
I mean a boxing match is obviously a
fight,
but it's not in the new definition and
the new definition it a fight is a mixed
martial arts fight where you're in.
Even then there's rules that are
applied,
right?
Right.
So like there's no eye gouging.
There's no ball kicks,
there's no hitting to the back of the
head.
You can't elbow some of the back of the
head,
which is in a way healthier for the
athletes involved,
but in another way more delusional
because it removes a very dangerous at.
Like Eddie Bravo is always talking about
that,
that when guys used to take guys back in
the early days,
what they would do instantly his elbow
to the back of the head,
like it didn't matter if you defend the
choke or not.
If someone starts smashing the back of
your head,
you're fucked.
It's a terrible position to be in that.
That is removed from mma.
So because that's removed from mma,
you almost have to look at an mma fight,
which is absolutely a fight as in a way
kind of a match.
A mixed martial arts math because the
rules are so rigid,
where much more loose than boxing but
still rigid.
So you've got a Jujitsu match for sure.
Not really a fight because you get leg
kicked,
you can't get elbowed in the face,
you're not going to get need into a
coma.
It's a totally different experience than
a fight and it's almost disrespectful.
Some ways to call a Jujitsu match,
a fight rather,
they would like to refer to it as fight,
so nothing wrong with that.
Right?
If you don't know and you're just
looking at it from the outside,
boxing matches more like a fight,
right?
Because you're hitting each other in
this grave danger.
You're really trying to kill each other,
right?
I mean you're smashing each other,
Not trying to kill,
but you are using your,
your explosive force on a person trying
to take them out and it's a very
dangerous encounter with severe
consequences for your brain.
Yeah.
That's a fight a lot,
but it's a fight with very limited
rules.
Yeah,
because like a Meu Thai fighter,
a really good more Thai fighter would
kill most really good boxers if the
boxer didn't know what was going on
because they're really good Thai
fighter,
it's gonna be very hard to hit them to
get that close to him and he's going to
start kicking your legs immediately.
What's more time?
It's Thai boxing because they have more
weapons,
right?
Legs to kick the legs a lot and they'll
push you away with their front kick.
There's so much stuff that you're not
gonna be able to do.
Box will be way better with his hands,
but more Thai fighter is usually pretty
good with their hands already.
Especially good enough to land a
shitload of kicks on you and keep you
from getting in range and if you did get
arranged,
they clench you in.
They need in the body and the elbow you
in the head.
It's a way more complete striking system
than regular box.
Do you feel like there's too many rules?
Like do you feel like it should be just
opened up in mma?
Like make it real?
Yes and no because I like,
I like specialists like I love that
conor Mcgregor,
floyd mayweather fight because it was a
real specialist.
You got to see like a really elite high
level striker from MMA become almost
helpless against a world champion.
Probably the best advert box you get to
see this is what happens when a
specialist fight.
Someone who's really good at something
like me,
if I wanted to uh,
roll against someone who's like a real
high level Jujitsu black belt,
I would get,
I would get killed,
right?
But if you've got a really good jujitsu
black belt from the UFC,
they would kill me.
But a really good jujitsu black fruit
from the UFC.
Mike get killed by a really good Jujitsu
world champion.
It's like there's all these levels and
levels and the only way you achieve
those levels as true specialist,
like a true specialist,
is it such a different level?
Like if you watch,
you know,
Sanchez,
you ever heard of Sam Chai?
Thailand.
He's probably one of the greatest ever
combat sports athletes ever.
And he's fights every couple of weeks.
I followed him on instagram.
He's 36 years old,
he's.
He fights people way smaller than him
all the time and although he knocks a
lot of people out,
most of his fights are won by him just
doing shit to the opponent that they
just can't deal with.
He just kicks the shit out of him.
He hits them when they're not looking.
They don't know what he's doing.
He's so clever and fast or anything.
I mean he's just a wizard,
a technical wizard inside the ring and
when you watch him you realize like,
oh well there's levels even to this
thing.
This guy is such a specialist at anybody
outside of that,
like floyd mayweather wanted to fight
sand Chai lattes,
anti kick him.
It would be one of the most lopsided
fights you've ever seen.
It would be horrific to watch watching a
world class boxer just getting exposed
to legs kicked out from under him,
kicked in the face,
legs kicked out from under him.
No interface elbowed in the head.
Well,
don't you think mcgregor?
If he was allowed to do his thing?
Sure.
Right.
For sure.
Meanwhile,
Sanchez Chai could probably do that to
Mcgregor,
right?
There's levels and levels.
What Mcgregor and encountered with Floyd
Mayweather,
he would encounter in Thai boxing with
like a,
a fantastic one of the greatest ever.
And the guy like San shy.
So it sounds like the rules actually
make it more interesting.
They do have to become.
Right.
So the only way you find out who the
really best Jujitsu guys is,
you have to have them only compete in
Jujitsu,
right?
Because with strikings,
all this other stuff involved.
You hurt people with punches and knees,
but when you want to look at a complete
system,
complete system,
mixed martial arts is as close as it
comes without the elbows to the head
kicks when the down to the head on down
fighter and the stomps and the knees to
the head on a down fighter.
Right.
And then the really dirty shit like
eyeball pokes and the balls.
So it's always going to be a match.
You can't bite someone's nose off.
It's always going to be a match.
Right.
You know what I mean?
There's got to be some limit.
Yeah.
But you still call it a fight,
right?
So how,
how many hills to I have to run to get
back into my old shape?
Well,
I think it's this whole fucking God damn
delicious bread you're making.
That's an issue.
So,
you know what happened?
I uh,
I visited this a woman in Ohio who's
really good bakers.
Kate spreads anchors.
Yeah.
She's amazing.
And I saw it flower she had.
I'm like,
oh,
I gotta get that flower.
That's what I got to get this one out.
So I looked up online where she gets the
flower comes from Utah.
Whoa.
And the smallest you can get as a 50
pound bag.
So I have 2:50
pound bags of wheat and artists and all
purpose flour in my kitchen.
And I'm like,
I was thinking like if you were to eat
50 pounds of flour,
you would be a big fat.
So dude.
But the flower makes such a difference.
Huge difference.
You know,
what I discovered recently is a double
zero wheat pasta from Italy.
Double Zero.
Yeah.
You do.
Most folks don't.
Yeah.
Now Double Zeros.
What you use for pizza dough.
Yeah.
The good stuff,
right stuff,
and I also found out about heirloom
wheat,
heirloom wheat,
that most of what we're getting here in
the United States of good old Morocco is
a wheat that has been.
People love that term GMO.
Right.
It scares the shit out of people.
Gmos.
Super Organic.
Yeah.
Good.
All good thoughts.
But the reality is most of the wheat we
have,
according to,
you know maynard Kenyan from tool
[inaudible],
the singer of the singer.
He also owns a this great vineyard
owner,
right?
Yeah.
And a restaurant.
Oh yeah.
She was explaining to me.
He explained it on the podcast about the
differences between the wheat we have
today and the original wheat.
The wheat we have today has much more
complex gluten's in it and it's a larger
yield for the same area.
So when they would grow the old wheat,
they.
They didn't make as much of it,
but it was easier for a person to
digest.
Right.
Interesting.
Yeah.
There's a huge.
There's so many of these little farmers
and little.
Some are pretty big for being little,
but compared to what these giant things
are,
they really concentrate on growing the
wheat the way they used to be grown and
then the mill it the way it was.
Seeds though.
Yeah,
and it's.
It makes such a difference.
Like just.
I was like,
how big of a difference can it be just
in making the bread that I'm making a
huge.
I would imagine it tastes like,
like to lie natural.
Yeah.
It's earthy,
it's deep.
It's like it's really good.
Earthy,
earthy is good.
Now it made a big difference,
but now I've got to figure out how I'm
going to store 50 pounds of 100 pounds
of flour.
You'd probably have to do it in a
controlled environment.
No,
I gotta go bad.
You got to just put it in barrels.
Does it have to be dry and air or.
Yeah.
But it's good for a long time when you
do it that way.
Yeah.
Yeah,
and I'm,
I'm still learning and cranking out a
lot and giving it away and stuff and so
I'm going through a lot and won't sit
forever the way it's been described to
me,
the differences between the difference
of like a tomato that you get in a
grocery store today,
even a good one in comparison to an
heirloom tomato makes perfect sense that
those tomatoes that we have today,
like Neil degrasse Tyson did a speech
about this where someone was asking him,
not a speech,
but the answer to a question.
I think it might've been in one of those
talks that he does those town hall talk
and someone was asking him about Gmos
and he said virtually everything we eat
has been modified.
Yeah.
Everything from the oranges to the corn.
Like you wouldn't go want to go back to
the original corn.
It wouldn't taste good.
It wouldn't be a lot of yield to it,
but then the real problem is the corn
that we have today.
Not that easy for us to digest.
Right.
And not that good to eat a lot of it,
you know,
it's all like how much of it do you use?
Yeah,
but when you do eat a tomato,
like an heirloom tomato,
you get a farmer's market that this guy
grew in this tiny little farm and just
happens to have them that week.
Phenomenal.
But I don't think that's the same with
corn.
Now.
I think that golden sweet corn that we
have today that tastes like candy,
that's the best shit.
That's pretty good.
You know,
you put butter on that.
Yeah.
Wrap it in aluminum foil.
Put It on the grill.
Oh,
bullshit ass original pine cone.
Looking your heart as court.
Stupid people would hang that stupid
corner on their door on thanksgiving.
The Indian court up with that on
Annabelle.
Bullshit ass.
Multiracial.
Scaring children away.
Halloween.
It's still weird colored.
And he asked her,
what are you?
All kinds of shit.
Yeah.
Just just try and eat me if you can.
That was the original corn,
but it wasn't even that.
That's like,
it adds.
No,
that's.
Yeah.
That's,
that's the core.
And people put.
Wait,
what is that?
Cornell ooky corn,
children of the corn at some spooky
corn,
right?
They ever seen the original corn.
See if you can find original
corn plant images.
I still want to know how much tobacco
rowers get paid.
I couldn't find much.
The only thing I found was an article
about a guy that just started a
business.
It said somewhere in there that are as
cheap as they could be made was like
thirty cents a piece and it was
expensive as $5 a piece for the cigar
itself.
It didn't say that included,
uh,
the wells are a highly skilled wrapper
to do it.
So it might be being paid per,
per cigar.
They rule fifty cents per if they're
doing like a bunch in a row,
you know,
and it didn't say whoever wrote this did
a great job.
You did a fantastic job.
It's easy.
Draw,
easy draw.
Last name,
Nice Long,
great podcasts if you're into scars were
um,
Ari Shaffir sat down with Robert Kelly.
They smoke cigars.
And Bobby Kelly said,
is that what it really would like?
Bobby Kelly is a crazy fucking.
He's gonna smoke crazy with the cigars
or the original corn looked like,
like bullshit.
What?
Yeah,
that's the original corn is a size of a
quarter and the quarter with that.
Wow.
That is crazy.
The original corn versus the new corn.
Wow.
That's really wild.
Wild.
And that shit was all done through like
splicing.
Right?
Right.
That was natural.
Look with corn used to look like.
That's weird.
It looks like it looks like the route
that came out of your toilet to small,
big modern corn looks like the route.
That's crazy,
right?
I mean,
corn used to be this tiny little low
yield product.
Well,
that's jelly bean corn.
That's amazing.
Glass gem corn glass.
Gem Corn.
I bet that tastes like shit.
Yeah,
it's terrible.
That can't be good.
Otherwise people would eat it,
but yeah.
You ever get a cotton candy?
Grapes.
What is that?
Jamie?
Black.
Waxy corn.
What's black?
Wow,
that looks amazing.
It looks pretty good.
It looks like licorice.
Like you bite into it,
which is cool.
I would eat that.
I would eat dead too.
I would think that like if you went over
a clever person's house to interview
that black corn,
you'd be like,
experience even better.
What are those purple potatoes come from
Peru,
right?
That's probably the same area as this I
think.
Is it Peruvian purple potatoes and that.
Ooh,
look at that one.
That's crazy.
That looks like the alien from the
Geiger.
It's Dick.
Go back to that.
The tongue comes out and fucked his
jabs.
You in the head with that and then it,
it shoots the baby into your body.
You just within your just sitting there
eating dinner like in the wrong sport
grows out of your dead body.
I can't believe that,
uh,
that the corn didn't.
I think between the original core and
being that weird Nabi thing and the corn
that we have year round,
I think there's probably an era in there
were the corn tasted better,
right?
Like the life of the taiga,
the evolution of human beings to
technological superiority.
Where we're at today,
you got to meet it halfway.
That's the sweet spot.
The sweet spot where there's no stopping
it.
He's no stopping it.
We're moving forward,
there's no stopping it,
but maybe this spot is not sweet spot.
Just like living in a cave wasn't the
fucking sweet spot.
Right?
It was just a sweet spot for the time.
Yeah.
Right now you don't want to go live on
the tiger.
No.
Tom Pump.
I can't.
You can't?
No.
It'd be exhausted.
How are you going to bake your bread?
Am I going to make bread?
Flour.
You gonna have to grow it.
Oh my God.
You've got to mill your own bread.
Do you manage?
If you had to grow your own fucking
wheat to make your bread?
Yeah,
we would never make bread with judo.
May probably would.
Maybe I'll plant the seed right now.
Maybe you're gonna leave here.
You're going to be driving home your
electric car.
You're going to be thinking,
Hey,
fuck.
All this comedy bullshit when I do is
get a big piece of land and start
growing my own wheat and then chopping
it down,
make my own bread and have Tom Papa's
bread restaurant.
I've given this a lot of thought.
I have something,
so not about throwing it all away,
but there's something about a going
bigger and deeper into it.
It's kind of just draws you in.
I'm not even making decisions.
There's just like,
oh,
now I'm getting bigger things of flour
and it's just.
Yeah,
there's something very all consuming
about it.
Yeah,
it's good.
You know,
whenever you get something that gets
that,
it's rewarding and I like that it's
small.
I like that it's,
there's no bullshit around it.
There's no phone calls to be made.
It's just all on my own terms but does
in my control.
Does that appeal to you as an overall
life or does it appeal to you as a
vacation from the current life that you
enjoy?
Which is very hectic and kinda stressful
writing material,
performing,
traveling.
You know what it is?
I feel like A.
I don't know.
It's an interesting question.
I do feel like the process of making it
and doing it is a.
It matches up with writing really well.
When I'm.
When I'm at home and I'm writing a lot
and in between taking breaks and going
and tending to the bread and then coming
back to the writing that back and forth
is very satisfying.
Nice.
It is the best.
That was nice.
Yeah.
I often thought writing in some ways
releases you from the stress.
A lot of people find a performing.
The just writing.
Yeah.
I heard nor Mcdonald's.
It's that on his,
uh,
on his show that he just wants to write
books.
He just wants to write that before.
I've heard that before where people just
want to go internal and stop being.
I know,
but I former,
I feel like,
uh,
I,
I couldn't do that 100 percent.
I really love it.
I have this.
My Book's gonna come out next year.
It's a plug.
I see what you did sign up.
You can't even buy it yet,
but it is coming out soon.
Be planting seeds,
a planting seeds,
seeds for people to buy the book.
I see what you're doing and it's not
yet.
It's not like I'm plugging my Gig at
comics.
He can sign or anything.
Well,
you there,
when is that?
It's coming up next week.
Oh,
interesting.
No,
I,
I feel like I,
when I was
writing the book,
I got very deep into an I love coming in
with my coffee in the morning,
going to work for hours just in there,
tinkering with it,
playing with it.
It was very satisfying.
It makes sense,
but after,
after several days of not being onstage,
start getting itchy,
he get itchy.
It's not who I am.
Do you think that it's that you've
experienced these jolts of fun,
that you get from standup,
that you become addicted to these jolts
of fun and then seeing the happiness and
people's faces when they're laughing?
Yeah.
That relating to people,
that isolation of writing is okay,
but until I can take that idea out,
share it with other human beings.
That's what I'm.
For what you've designed yourself that
way.
Sort of like you look at the human race,
we've,
we've grown to this place where if you
made people like,
were you here during the heatwave?
Yeah.
Weird,
right?
Yeah.
It was intense.
It got intense.
It was a little spooky.
It was,
yeah,
because like really people were on edge.
Yeah.
Well,
quietly on edge waiting for the AC to
go.
Right.
If the AC goes down,
where are we going to deal with this?
Because this is not.
You have to just get in the shower all
day.
Yeah.
No,
it's intense when it's only got 110.
Yeah.
You can stay in the shade and you'll
stay reasonably cool,
but it's.
It's way hotter than you want it to be.
Yes.
You're not sleeping,
right?
No,
no.
Sweating like a pig.
Yeah,
like the people in Florida right now.
There's a lot of people that don't have
power.
Yeah,
and it's humid.
Hot as fuck.
Yeah.
Fans blowing.
No.
It's not good feeling where you're like,
oh,
I've always thought no disrespect people
from Florida,
but that's one of the reasons why people
think of people that live in the south
as being dull because the thing for the
longest time before they invented air
conditioning,
they,
those fucking people didn't have time to
think.
Deep core move quickly.
You're not going to think your best
thoughts when you fucking sweating like
a pig and you're exhausted all the time.
Why getting the power back on in Florida
could take weeks.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Fuck that.
That's rough.
It is rough weeks.
Why'd you bring up that?
Why'd you bring up the,
uh,
whether it was here during the heat wave
because it was so evident to me during
that time that we really can't even
exist in this environment without the
way we do and enjoy the way we live
without the modern conveniences of
electrical grid air conditioning units
and the delivery of food and all this
shit that we just get like super
accustomed to.
So we think now of life without that
stuff as being like impossible.
But at one point in time we were adapted
one point in time life without that,
like those fucking people that live in
the taiga,
the worst it gets for them as it gets
crazy cold,
they bundle up and they go inside and
they burn wood,
but they have like a whole system built
in to survive that environment.
For us,
that would be unthinkable.
Like your house doesn't have central Ac,
you don't have heat,
you don't have a thermostat.
Wait a minute.
Wait,
hold on.
See Walk in your house.
That thing doesn't glow in the wall and
show you the temperature you've walked
by.
It exists things.
Yeah.
It's not programmed where it's Kinda
knows I'm home.
Yeah.
A friend of mine's house,
you walk towards his thermostat and it
lights up.
It senses your senses.
You're there,
right?
Hey.
Yeah.
It shows you the temperature,
like it's off.
Like you'll step away.
It'll dim up and he's standing right in
front of it and it lights and like this
is freaky.
Yeah.
It's pretty nice.
People don't have that man.
They have.
Windows does shut.
Yeah.
They fire.
Fire keeps the heat in.
Bundle up.
Now I couldn't put animal skins on.
Yeah.
That's what people do now.
I'm not doing that.
Yeah,
I'm not.
No.
So we've adapted for sure to this.
You and I have adapted to this.
The question is,
who's happier?
What's it better?
Is it better?
I'm pretty happy when I walk in after,
after that heat wave and I would walk
into my house.
You take your shoes off and your bare
feet on the cold tile.
I'm pretty happy.
I'm happier than the tiger guy.
Yeah.
Watch TV.
All these hurricanes brewing in the goal
G.
Yeah.
But I've found that,
uh,
that writing is very,
and uh,
as I was writing,
I was reading a lot of writers and stuff
and it's very isolating.
Like the more you write,
the more you are shutting out the world,
the more you are you.
It's a hermit's life.
It is,
it really is.
In a way.
It's not a,
uh,
you are very much within your own head
and eating up a lot of time just being
by yourself.
It's a,
it can be rewarding for sure,
but it's a.
If you were to write all the time like
that,
it's pretty isolating.
Well,
it's also in a lot of ways,
almost like a mental marathon because
you're,
you're on this one thing for a long
time.
Sitting there staring at this thing and
you're writing and you're thinking about
it and you're focusing on it and you're
going back at it and you thinking about
it and you focus on becomes like a part
of your daily thoughts even when you're
not doing it.
Sometimes.
What was really remarkable was when
you're writing your standup in blocks,
it's like chunks and I was thinking,
how am I going to keep track of like a
whole book,
but your subconscious really does like I
know exactly where things are.
I would glide through it and no,
I think I have to change this part and
see on my notes.
Yes indeed.
That is where I was going to change it.
It is.
Your brain starts to take in all that
information and treat it like chunks.
You know what I mean?
It's no different really than writing
your standup.
Do you.
Do you take notes like chapter chapter
notes,
like you have like a notebook that you
have sitting on the side
and you like say chapter one,
here's all the things that I like or
don't like or not that specifically,
but if there's something that I can't
wrestle to the ground and I'm like,
I gotta fix that ending.
I'll just write on the side Pan,
page 35,
you know,
and then keep going.
And you writing like this.
What's the,
what's the subject of the book?
It's a funny essays about family life.
Okay.
So it's all just different.
Different chapters about everybody in
your family,
your parents,
your kids,
your uncles,
cousins,
everything that makes up family.
So it's all these little,
they're like 300 pages and each one is
probably four pages,
five pages,
you know what I mean?
How long have you been working on it?
I'm a little over a year.
Ooh.
Yeah.
And it's like this week it goes back and
I don't get it back.
Who?
This is it?
Yeah,
this is great.
Yeah.
Done.
I'm not like sick of it.
No.
But yeah,
pretty proud of parts of it,
but every time you look at it,
you're like,
how did I let that go?
This is terrible.
This is so corny.
How did I let that joke in the way that
you know?
But uh,
do you find that sometimes you have an
idea that you're not getting out
totally,
but you leave it as is,
as a place holder and you review it
later.
Yeah.
Like maybe you feel like there's
something in this idea,
but whatever I have right now is shit.
Yeah.
But maybe there's something if I just
leave it there like that,
maybe I'll come at it from a different
angle,
but at least then I know to think about
this one subject that I thought had some
promise.
Yes.
One hundred percent,
100 percent.
And I really feel like it kind of taught
me how much your subconscious goes to
work on it without you being conscious.
Like you don't realize that your brain
is actually going,
it's going to work on this.
When you shut out,
shut the computer and walk away,
you think that's it?
Your brain is still going at it without
you even being aware that it's
happening.
He ever read Stephen King on writing a
book.
It's a great book.
The things.
One of the things I thought was the most
shocking was that he doesn't really like
have a,
like a whole outline of the stories
started writing them.
It's crazy.
It's just as an idea and just go,
yeah.
Which is brilliant.
You fucking amazing.
You gotTa Trust Yourself.
You just gotta you gotTa.
I mean,
he's a brilliant mind,
but you know,
when I was a kid,
his books were thought of as like fluff,
but if you read Stephen King,
you weren't really reading.
He's.
Yeah,
well that happens when you're really
popular.
It was a little bit of that,
right?
Um,
but it was also that,
oh,
you're just reading monster stories.
It's so stupid.
He should be reading about depressed
heroin users.
Then you'd be like,
exact,
deep.
Yeah.
Middle aged crisis in Europe,
you know,
hey man,
this is alphabet city.
In the 19 sixties these people were
doing smack you listening to Lou Reed
and punching each other.
That guy.
I mean,
how you ever go to the bookstore and
look at the Stephen King Section in the
bookstore.
It's a whole.
It's a whole part of
the store.
This guy just cranks it out.
Amazing.
There's definitely errors though.
There's like.
You know what?
I feel like.
I feel like there's drugs and no drugs.
Stephen King drug.
Stephen King is the shining,
carry,
cujo dead zone zone.
All the crazy shit.
All the dark weird,
twisted.
No inhibition whatsoever.
Shit.
And then he's like more content now and
probably a healthier person than the
stores aren't quite as fucked up as it.
Yeah,
it was fucked up.
But there's that one.
Mr.
Mercedes,
the newer ones,
the newer ones.
Oh,
he's still got it in him for sure.
Dark.
Oh,
for sure.
Mark.
What's not just dark,
like if you go back and read carry.
It's not just dark.
It's like the psychological profile of
this poor torment.
A young girl with telekinetic powers is
fucking fantastic.
He has nailed it.
Oh my God.
Point where you want her to make those
kids heads explode.
You want her to cause accidents.
'Em Girl.
These assholes.
Like finally the tormented and picked on
girl has an option.
I mean,
he made it perfect.
He made really created the ultimate
outsider,
some poor kid that was unfortunate to be
born into a situation where a mother was
completely psychotic cunt.
Yeah.
And people were trying to fucking throw
a pig's blood honor and run her over
with a car.
So mean.
Yeah.
But she and she,
they faked that fucking handsome guy was
going to go to the prom with her dump
blood on her and they all thought it was
fun and they were laughing at her and
she got back and I'm all because we
realized that for the worst case
scenario for a human is someone that
could do that to some poor misfortunate
girl like carry without killing her.
These are the worst people that you
could imagine.
She had this fucking ace in the hole.
Power they never saw coming.
Fucking great.
So great.
He's amazing.
He's good hazing.
But I remember people telling me like,
that's all fluff.
I'd be like,
pet cemetery must shining.
Read that book.
Shaming is not fluff.
It's not fluff.
It's not flopping.
Book is fucking fantastic.
Oh my God.
And the book,
that guy goes crazy slow.
It takes a while.
That's what he didn't like about the
original Jack Nicholson version,
the Kubrick version,
which is fantastic,
but it was a different story.
I can see the argument that that story
was more adaptable to a film that takes
place over,
you know,
two plus hours or whatever.
Whereas his book,
it would have to be like a 30 hour
movie.
Yeah.
It's a long process of Jack.
Maybe 30 hours.
Yeah.
When he really starts going nuts and the
family realizes he's actually losing his
fucking mind and taken over by something
that lives in this house.
It's good.
He felt like Jack Nicholson,
I think if I remember correctly,
his,
his criticism,
the Jack Nicholson seemed crazy
immediately.
Oh really?
He was already crazy.
Like either hurt the kid wants.
When he was drinking,
he was fucked up.
I don't know if that was in the book,
I don't remember,
but that Jack Nicholson's character was
too crazy right away.
It wasn't enough of a transition like
was Chad and Chad
just check the,
uh,
the one thing I took away from that,
from his book on writing was,
uh,
just get to the end,
don't share it,
don't talk about it,
just keep going,
get to the end,
don't judge yourself,
just get to the end and then start going
to work on it.
And uh,
that really was helpful getting to the
end of this because.
And then it actually became really fun
going back and fixing it and fixing it
up.
And even like just the clarity,
like,
just make it simple.
Just make it,
get this message across,
like why am I taking three paragraphs,
repeating myself,
pare it down,
peel it off,
make it clear for the,
for the reader.
And he didn't want to go in circles.
Make this very like,
oh,
at times I'll read articles in the paper
or something.
And it's like not understanding it.
It's not that I'm not understanding is
that this isn't written well,
this isn't clear.
That's your job.
Like just going back and trying to
clear.
I mean like sometimes when you have a
bit and you're like,
you're working on new stuff for your
stand up and you have something,
it's like this big chunk and then when
you're done working on it,
it's down to like five lines [inaudible]
you learned how to say it so
effectively.
So direct.
Yeah.
And you realize the parts that just you
were enjoying them but they were
tripping you up the whole bit.
Right?
They were getting in the way.
They were like,
you're asking the audience to think
about this,
why?
It's just getting in the way.
Just
confusing the clarity of the original
thought.
You know,
a already has this piece of paper that
he has glued to the top.
This keyboard that's a hemingway quotes
is the first draft of everything is
Shit.
Oh Nice.
Yeah,
that's great.
It takes the pressure off.
Well,
it's also real.
It's like really,
really just get it out there and don't
think that it's done.
And Hemingway writing.
Yeah.
He,
his first draft was shit.
So yeah,
my little stuff is going to end up shit.
It's like Stephen King Hemingway was
fucked up all the time,
like Stephen King's early days was
Stephen King really fucked up.
Oh.
Oh,
he was a book.
Oh Man.
I don't remember that part.
Yeah.
Do you mean he was just drinking cases
of budweiser and fucking doing coke and
he said he didn't even remember writing.
Carrie what?
Yeah,
I didn't even remember it.
Now it came in a haze or is it cujo?
Holy Cow.
Carrier.
Cujo.
Cujo didn't remember writing Cujo I
think it was in A.
I don't know.
I might,
I might be wrong.
It might be carried,
but just he was one of those books.
What does it Cujo.
Thank you.
Wow.
So to be so blasted it didn't remember
writing one of the great horror books
ever.
Oh my God.
And a horror book
about a rabid dog or a giant rabbit dog
that used to be everybody's friend.
So scary.
I read that as a kid like in a summer
and just you were in that car with that
kid with the mom just like,
oh yeah,
God,
his just slobber on the.
On the window next to you.
Dude.
So he was that messed up?
Yeah,
it was selfish.
Yeah.
I mean he was doing everything.
When did he get clean?
Years back.
I think his wife put the hammer down.
Yeah.
They gave like a family and friends
staged an intervention.
You're around that time.
Oh yeah,
here.
Got that bad.
So doesn't say see late eighties I
guess.
Yeah.
See,
so I'm not,
I don't want to say that he couldn't
have written amazing stuff without
drugs.
No.
But the original stuff that he did,
he was.
But well,
I mean was it that he was just fucked up
and he was writing amazing stuff or was
it that he was writing amazing stuff
cause he was fucked up.
But clearly it has an effect on your
mind and your mind is where all your
creativity allegedly is coming from.
Right?
I mean,
you're writing and you're concentrating.
The way you're thinking about things
directly affects the work.
So if you're thinking about things on
coke and drinking and you got this
psychotic overview of life on earth and
the interactions that people have with
each other.
And.
And this is what you're right,
this is how you're writing influenced by
these drugs as a giant effect on
creativity.
Sure.
But without talent to harness it and you
know,
Oh yeah,
totally get you.
If you don't have that talent that he
has unquestionably,
you can get just fucked up and then just
you don't do anything with it.
It sit in your room,
you know,
but he,
it's a real talent there that then the
drugs influenced that.
It's manipulating that giant talent.
I mean,
you could also say the same about a lot
of great comics like Kennison and prior,
obviously they had a great relationship,
bad relationship with some drugs,
but there were also fucking super
talented on top of that for sure.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's a fascinating thought,
right?
It's like what?
What are your thoughts and where,
where are these coming from?
Are they coming from the environment
that you live in?
The things you've been exposed to,
the pros and the cons,
the goods and the bads.
He'll be here.
I'm sure you have,
but I'll ask it anyway,
but you ever hear,
I'm a singer,
songwriters.
Talk about where the songs come from.
Privilege.
Yeah,
but they,
a lot of times they talk about catching
them out of the air that they're there.
They weren't like they didn't come from
me.
They all have this overwhelming feeling
like it came from somewhere else.
What do you make of that?
For sure.
Think they,
you know,
Steven pinker calls it the muse.
He uses the expression,
the Muse or the,
you know,
the idea of the muse and that even if
it's not like a real muse,
like some sort of a guardian thing,
but treat it like it is with respect to
like show up to work in that musical
show up more often.
Like
tune it in and have it come to you.
But I think it comes back to what we're
saying about ego and like getting out of
your own way.
Like sometimes when you're writing,
you're so immersed in these thoughts and
these ideas that you are out of your own
way,
that that tunnel.
Then the booze and the coke and the weed
or whatever the fuck you're doing helps
you stay in that crazy zone of just
letting these ideas sort of create
themselves in your mind and letting the
story play itself out in your brain,
but how much of it is from within your
brain and how much is it in the ether?
It's good question.
Does that mean and what is it?
What does that mean?
Floating around in the ether and letting
in you just being a thing where it can
kind of show up.
Yeah.
You know,
is it just harnessing us?
I mean because whenever you talk about
meditating or even the yoga or the
Jujitsu,
all that stuff we're talking about,
it is a relationship to the universe,
right?
Right.
It is a relationship to these forces
that are outside of ourself.
It's interesting.
It is,
and it's probably.
I mean,
every human being is a combination of so
many different experiences in genes and
environment and the culture they live
in.
I mean,
there's so many different factors that
would effect your creativity to.
There's so many different factors that
would affect the way unique ideas enter
into your head.
Yeah.
And you know how much.
How much respect do you pay to those
ideas?
How much time do you spend alone with
those ideas?
Right.
Can you focus on a lot of different
things?
Like if you were writing,
can you focus on your act and another
project?
No.
It's hard,
right?
No,
I'm not good at that.
I've tried that.
I don't,
I don't do so well at that.
I write different things,
but if I have like a main project,
like the main I'm trying to do a special
or something like that.
The main project,
it's always got to be the standup and
then all these other things that I write
are just fishing for more standup.
Right.
You know,
so I don't.
A lot of times I don't write like try to
sit down and write a specific joke.
Yeah.
I get a joke and then I right on the
joke,
but I get a joke from writing blogs more
like almost like essays.
So I'll,
I'll start thinking about a subject in
this way.
I'm not restricted to a punchline
format,
I just,
I'm just trying to like explore all the
different things that I think about this
and then I might find one or two gems in
there and then I extract those and I go,
okay,
well how do I get that jam?
Turn it into how does.
I know there's a thought there that
makes sense.
Yeah.
How do I do that without all that other
bullshit?
How do I get to it quick?
I really think that great standup is
like poetry because that's all pairing
you down to this one simple way to
deliver all of that thing in that blog.
Right?
That's why tweets are so good.
Like you know,
I'm Ian Edwards was telling me about
that,
but like writing tweets and writing like
little face posts,
facebook posts like having real limited.
He would just sit there and try to write
like really funny shit on twitter and
that forces you to boil it down to 140
characters,
you know?
Yeah.
It's a skill you had eight is the
definite like you,
you learn how to have like a quickly
impacting thought as opposed to like
some long or like he ever read.
I mean I've been guilty of it too.
I've written some stuff like that,
but the long drawn out stupid shit that
could have been like parse down and it's
almost like,
come on man,
don't put this out there yet.
First draft.
Yeah,
right.
Oh my God,
yeah.
The world is filled with those specials
right now.
Those specials,
those articles and so much so much to
just kinda hanging out.
Yeah.
You know,
it's a,
it's an interesting thing,
but I really do.
I did like the,
the process of,
of having to write it,
you know what I mean?
Like knowing that someone's,
someone out there is waiting for him.
This thing in it was kind of a,
it was pretty cool.
That's why people like doing specials
too because you know that like,
Hey,
I have to film this thing in six months
so I have x amount of work to do.
You've got to get it done.
Right.
As opposed to if you don't have a
hanging out.
Yeah,
just doing sets.
How much you writing?
I'm writing a little.
Yeah,
I'm doing it.
He realized that same new joke is six
months old or a year old or two years
old.
Years old or I mean how many guys you
know like that,
but there's so much comfort in the port.
You know,
you're already in port.
You don't want to go back out to that
ocean of ideas.
Right,
exactly.
It's nice and safe over here.
I've been working on his house and I got
to go out again.
I got this act.
I got a nice and honed the hurricane's
coming out my beach side house.
I got to rebuild.
I can't possibly,
I can't do that.
Look,
I can't grow.
I'm 70 years old.
There's no learning.
It's over.
I'm done.
You are what you are.
I'm done,
man.
You are what you are.
So uh,
can we talk about what you did
yesterday?
Sure.
Uh,
because you sent me a pretty cool
picture.
Oh,
the elk.
Oh my God.
Holy.
Do that once a year.
That was massive.
Yeah,
it's huge.
Big Animal.
How Big Wild Elk?
Thousand pounds probably.
She's big animal.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
And how long?
Uh,
did it just come where you set up in one
spot and it kind of crossed your path?
Was a couple of days of trying to get
close to one couple days that that's,
that's really quick.
Wow.
Usually it's a lot more days,
but you know,
you're obviously sometimes you'll have
encounters with an elk,
like your very first morning.
It was a picture of the rack on that is
amazing.
It's a big animal that is huge rack.
Yeah.
That's the most one of the most majestic
of all wild animals.
That is amazing.
I mean that is a mountain of an animal.
These animals get killed so often by
mountain lions,
like mountain lions in particular.
And how old is he?
You think there's,
I don't know.
I mean that's.
How long did it take to grow that rack?
You know,
what's really crazy?
They drop them off every year and they
regrow them quick every year.
Yep.
So that grows that quickly within a
couple months.
Oh my God.
Really insane.
It's like one of the.
It looks like it's growing things in
nature.
I would think that was around for 20
years.
No,
no,
they,
they dropped those off every year.
Oh my God.
That's where you can tell a very
specific,
like there's very specific
characteristics of certain antlers and
you can tell by the sheds if it's the
same antler,
if you catch them like a year later,
man.
Oh Man.
One,
one Arrow,
one arrow.
Really?
What do you aim for the lungs?
Like the vitals,
the lungs.
The heart kills him.
Like the lungs get deflated and they die
quick.
He,
he fell within five seconds.
Really?
From an Arrow?
Yeah.
And then it takes a few seconds for them
to expire,
but never knew we were there.
He had no idea where were there.
So how long were you in the spot where
you were?
We,
we were trying to get to him for a
couple of hours because he was
screaming.
They scream when they're trying to get
laid and they tried to pick up chicks.
Oh really?
Fight each other to the death.
We find dead ones.
They're really.
Yeah.
You find them all the time.
They,
one of them they found though had a
mountain lions,
a claw stuck in its head,
which is really crazy.
You're really.
Yeah.
They found this one that had been chewed
up and uh,
when they,
um,
you know,
when I think one of them dies,
they want to find out like what killed
them and think that you,
you bring the skull to like fish and
game and they do an examination on
whatever they can to see what's going on
at the same.
It was poached,
you know,
sometimes people will shoot an animal
and then I'm just,
they're not supposed to be there.
Like there's people are assholes,
man.
Like Ted Nugent,
a place in.
Some people are obviously,
Ted nugent has a place in Michigan and
it's this big giant fenced in deer park
that he has hundreds of acres.
And uh,
one day while he was not there,
someone killed like all of his books.
So they climbed the fence,
just shot them all and just shot him and
left them.
Yeah.
I just shot him and I'm like,
people have done terrible things like
that.
So I think there's one,
they have to think about that they find
a dead one and also they have to think
about what's killing it.
Is it a bear that's killing it?
Not that usual.
They're pretty big for a grown bear to
attack that bear and a grizzly bear in
America or there's no grizzlies in
California rather.
But um,
they do get jacked by grizzlies in
Wyoming really.
Especially their,
their babies.
Almost all their babies would have
grizzly fight it for food or protect
itself.
No,
for food.
Oh yeah.
Yeah,
it was.
You don't have to protect yourself from
an elk.
Right?
You have to protect yourself from a
moose.
Moose,
uh,
try to fuck you up.
Yeah.
Different animals.
They evolve around grizzly bears all the
time.
So they were up in Alaska.
There's a certain parts of America they
are too,
but I ran into one in dental.
Ronald.
Yeah.
You
can find them in Colorado.
In Wyoming.
I think I told you that story.
I came around the trail.
We were back country for a couple of
weeks and we just came around this
trail.
It was a baby moose,
like on the middle of the trail are
like,
oh,
it's so cute.
It was like he just heard it's mom's got
to be around the year and this.
Yeah,
this we got out of there really quick.
A friend of mine has a ranch,
British Columbia,
and he was on his horse and he got too
close to the baby.
So the mother Moose start chasing them
at full clip.
Oh Man.
It was fucking terrifying because the
Moose is so much bigger than his horse.
Gigantic.
Oh,
he was on a horse on a horse and he's
just hoping that the horse can get away
from this fucking Moose sprinting at
them and if the most will knock you off
the horse and stomp you to death.
She's there.
Yeah.
That is scary.
You catch a mama when she's around her
babies and she decides you're a problem.
And what about the out?
Does that have a Laker you?
Would that run you down?
Like if it's all you and felt
threatened?
No,
they're not as aggressive.
They're not the same.
There'll be a mean.
They would they.
If you got close to them,
especially during,
like right now,
which is called the Rut,
which is when once a year they get laid.
Once a year they grow these giant
antlers and they get ready to fight.
Those antlers are not to fight off
predators that.
To fight each other.
Yeah.
They go to another dude.
Yup.
They go to war for smash each other for,
for chicks.
Really craziest animals of all time.
That's why scream man,
like our lord of the rings out.
It's like,
oh my.
Yeah.
And then the females go let out.
This may sound like kind of give me some
deck.
And they're like,
I've got some
different.
Different
it is.
He yelling so she'll come to him.
He's just yelling.
So she'll come to him.
She's mewing.
So here you listen to this here.
This is from Youtube.
Terrifying elk scream.
This is what they sound like.
That looks just like the one.
It gets louder than that though.
So it's all it's got or is it just keep
going.
He's adorable.
Yeah.
That's not too loud.
That's it.
That's weak.
Look at that big glass rack.
Whoever put that video up,
that is a lie.
It's not terrified.
Not terrified here.
That bitch.
You better stay home if you're in your
tent at night and you heard that you'd
be a little scared to see if you could
find a better one because there's some
awesome one amazing elk bugle.
So you were in one spot for a couple of
hours after you heard that.
We spotted him in the distance.
We spotted him on the hill with
binoculars and then you've got to play
the wind.
You got to get close to him.
You got to figure out which way the wind
is blowing.
So he didn't smell you?
Yeah.
The wind changes as the day goes on
because the.
The ground heats up.
What is this
crazy?
How about that?
That's scary.
Is moves going to war in Alaska?
Moose battle.
They go to war,
like run on people's lawns and shit.
Fuck up their cars.
She's,
I mean there's so big.
A Moose is like twice the size of an
elk.
Twice the size.
Oh yeah.
Moves.
Get to like eight mooses misses two
pieces.
They it's really big and get to like
1800 pounds.
Holy Cow.
They're huge.
They're so big.
They don't even look real cheese.
I saw one that my friend Ben,
a shot in Alaska for NBC in British
Columbia and when it was walking across
the road,
there was like a dirt road that we were
wrong.
We saw walk from one section,
the forest into the neck.
It looked like.
Remember that war of the worlds movie
with Tom Cruise with thing child legs,
like walking over cars.
Like Holy Shit.
Can you eat moose?
Oh yeah.
Do you ever hunt for Moose?
Yeah,
I shot once.
that at that time,
man,
I shot a moose.
That's Moose right there.
This is it.
A real young Moose.
That's why it doesn't have much antlers.
Have a big asset of Atlanta.
What's better to eat?
This is the most redneck.
You really can't say it.
What's better to eat?
Moose is fantastic.
Moose and elk are real similar.
Similar is really good to know.
All wild game.
If it's healthy and it's prepared
correctly and taken care of correctly,
it's got an amazing taste to it.
It's just really like nutrient dense
protein dense,
very different than any other edits.
Again,
if you want to eat meat in my eyes,
like this is the best meat for you and
the best case scenario because it's just
not like a factory farmed animal and
kill it.
It's fate is sealed by mountain lions or
bears or wolves depending on where it is
or starvation or freezing to death and
it has a very short life.
Yeah.
Oh really?
I mean if,
if you find a nine year old elk,
Holy Shit.
How's that?
Even possible.
Yeah.
Fifty percent of them in grizzly bear
areas,
they get killed by bears when they're
babies.
That's a high percentage of fonds.
One out of two fonds get killed deer
fawns too.
And a lot of grizzly bear infested
areas.
Wow.
Yeah.
Uh,
I tried making that elk steak that you
gave me an eye.
I've messed it up.
Yeah.
Well,
you gotTa Cook it very lightly.
You don't want to like cook.
You should use a meat thermometer.
I'll give you.
It wasn't long.
I did a short amount of time,
but it was wrong.
Uh,
I think he said that,
uh,
there's some layer that.
Oh,
the silver skin.
Yeah.
Fascia.
I didn't take that.
Well,
I gave you a wrapped one that was from
the butcher.
What was it?
A roaster steak.
Like a steak.
Do you remember what?
See what is the,
there's a white,
it's like film that they keep on
sometimes to sort of retain moisture.
And when you,
when you see it,
it's like the Fascia on the outside of
meat and you have to slice that off.
It wasn't like a real visible thing.
Yeah,
it's really thin and sometimes it's in
between the structure of the milestones,
you've got to find it and cut it out or
eat around it.
It's just a different kind of animal.
The taste was good.
Was just very.
Yeah,
chew,
Chew.
That's that part you've got to cut out.
That's all it is.
Good though.
The ground.
Oh yeah.
That's just like for burgers and Chili
and all kinds of eggs in the morning.
Oh,
it's fantastic.
It's so good.
And again,
you don't have to worry about any
bullshit.
It's no hormones by antibiotic.
That's the worst part.
Like it's an animal that lived wild.
I don't like the idea of just blindly
ordering meat like when I'm out because
of not knowing where it came from or not
knowing you know,
worse.
How about knowing?
Yeah.
Even worse.
So you think about like what the animal
was.
Yeah.
No.
Suffering.
We're in a weird place where we're
jammed into these boxes of people,
people,
giant fucking populations and gotta get
these people food and so they want.
They don't want to know.
They don't know where it came from.
No,
no.
I know.
I think about how many people are
looking for lunch every day.
I mean,
how do you feed this number of people
that go to a Pastrami sandwich place?
Get a fucking big corn beef with Swiss
and mustard and you sitting there with a
friend eating at Jerry's Deli.
Have a great time.
Thank you.
What the hell?
No thought whatsoever.
To the whole process of what makes corn
beef.
How do you get that?
Where'd that come from?
Where is that?
Yeah.
No thought.
No thought at all.
It's creepy,
you know,
fucking weird man.
But what do you do?
There's so many of us do,
can't do anything,
like there's no way you can obviously do
something,
but I'm saying like the situation that
we're in right now,
it has to be resolved,
but it can't be resolved instantly
because to try to get all these people,
some sort of ethically raised animals,
um,
pasture fed animals that aren't forced
to eat some shit they're not supposed to
eat.
So they're unhealthy to get your
vegetables all free of pesticides,
but also high yield.
You protect them from insects and pasts
and bullshit and disease and don't you
feel like it's going to have to be like
there's this new,
I think it's called better burger,
but that's like a,
a plant based Burger.
Yeah.
That,
that almost looks like it's bleeding.
Like it actually has like a,
like,
have you tried it?
I haven't tried it yet,
but people are really.
Have been talking about it a lot lately.
Don't confuse,
um,
farm raised plants with not having any
consequences though.
That's another problem that people have
when they look at grain in particular
and they look at this,
the idea of like grain being completely
ethical.
I'm not saying don't eat grain was
saying if you look at those gigantic
combines that chew up all that grain,
when you go over those fields,
after they'd been freshly cut,
you see vultures all over circling
because there's a ton of fucking things
that got killed and those blades,
rodents and rodents and rabbits and all
kinds of shit.
Occasionally Fonz,
you know,
if someone fucks up and rick's Fonz
apparently will,
when they're scared,
when they're really young,
they just stay put.
They're scared and they get run over by
shit,
but how are you going to feed 7 billion
people that don't feel like you know.
Here's the key.
Here's the key man.
Preservatives without preservatives,
like everybody wants everything to be
natural and organic.
It's totally true,
but without preservatives,
it's very difficult to get supplies of
shit and stockpile things and to have
things in surplus.
I mean,
other than grains,
beans and canned things,
you know,
you'd have to catch everything,
but a lot of shipping and how we move
stuff around,
how long we want stuff to sit on the
shelves and stuff to stay fresh and want
to avoid mold by putting stuff into the
voids mold.
It also fucks with the natural gut flora
that we have right in our seat.
I'm like a scientist.
You're with this repeating shit I read,
but isn't it crazy how passionate people
like I talked about that I was a eight,
like a Vegan for a couple of years on my
podcast.
We got more hate comments like people
are so,
uh,
like,
like passionate,
like screw you eating that way.
What do you mean?
I,
I always eating that way.
I wasn't saying you have to eat that
way,
but there is an anger if you
show them a different way of living or
eating,
just eating.
Well,
they look at you as a person who's
responsible for the death and suffering
of animals,
right?
Yeah.
That's what it is.
Right?
And they wanted to show that they are in
a better moral position and they feel
genuinely outraged by your eating meat.
But it's the other side too.
If you say that you eat like a Vegan,
mediators come at you and say,
who the hell do you think you are?
Yeah.
Oh,
you're good bro.
How long have you been eating dirks?
Isn't it weird?
That is weird.
Like,
well who do you care what it is?
It doesn't make any sense.
The mediator ragging on the Vegan to me
doesn't make any sense at all unless
it's just like you ever meet a woman
that is just so mad at men because she's
ran into a few fucked up man.
You can't even talk to them.
Right?
Yeah.
People just trying to be nice to.
You won't let that happen.
Like every man.
His Shit.
Right.
That's sort of like.
I feel like maybe some meat eaters that
shit on Vegans,
they get mad because vegans are so
proselytizing.
It's such a common thing to be a
proselytizing vegans that mediators like
almost like attack first first.
Right?
You know?
Yeah.
Like screw you.
You're not going to make me feel bad
about.
I do.
Yeah,
but
then there's also,
there's a legit thought point that could
be made that the people that are a lot
of the people maybe that are shitting on
vegans and veganism,
they're doing so because they don't want
to address their own complicity in the
suffering of animals and they don't want
to think about it.
You make me think about it.
I just want to go to Carl's Jr Bacon and
Jalapeno Cheddar thing with.
Yeah,
there's that too.
Yeah.
You can't deny.
Yeah,
and it's not.
There's no absolute.
It's not one or the other.
It's very possible that there's a bunch
of shit going on.
Yeah,
but that the idea that you could get mad
at someone for eating Vegan,
that seems crazy.
It does increase,
but I think that people are so connected
to what they eat that it.
It brings up this.
It's a team thing.
Yeah.
Right.
It's like we were talking about a lot of
along the same.
How many God damn vegans out there have
the word Vegan and their twitter profile
or their facebook profile or their
instagram.
Jesus fucking Christ,
right?
You're wearing it like a badge of honor
and they feel like they're going to help
the world with this whole plant based
plant based,
but if you wrote like mediator Tom,
Papa mediator on the,
you know,
unless you run a TV show like Midi,
there was Steve Sportsmen's outdoor
channel.
Unless you're doing that.
Yeah,
you would never do that,
right?
You could write plant based,
you know like,
Hey,
plant based and plant based and people
write that in their profile.
It's not Vegan.
Happy Vegan,
healthy Vegan,
Vegan.
I want you to know what I am,
what I stand for.
Athletic Vegan,
like there's so many people that have
that in their name profile.
It's so obvious what you're doing mean.
Some of them.
I just want to be part of a team.
I just want to be more of a healthy
lifestyle.
I'm promoting the what's gonna Save the
world and promoting and I know they
believe that [inaudible].
I know they believe that,
but I think we tend to look at.
She liked the entire thing,
right?
We tend to look at the entire group of
people like we have to stop eating meat,
look at what we're doing to the
environment.
Yeah,
well some of us definitely don't have to
eat meat.
You can do whatever you want and we
should all look at factory farming and
say,
this is despicable and this is horrific
that we've allowed our,
our civilization to accept this.
Yeah.
In our inside of our borders.
Right?
That this is a barbaric practice is
terrifying because it's a complete
denial of like the natural order of
life.
Instead you're like,
no,
I'm might just capture this life a cage
it up and then shoot it when it's ready.
Yeah.
Ooh.
That way it stays tender because it
doesn't move like this dark.
Yeah.
To me,
what makes sense to me and everybody has
her own thoughts on this,
it makes sense to me is to just go out
in the wild and get it yourself if you
can.
Yeah.
Everybody can't know.
I know people don't have the time.
Right.
And I that too.
Yeah,
I get that.
I don't.
I'm not telling anybody what to do,
but for me,
I was at a point in 2012 where I was
trying to decide if I was going to be a
Vegan or vegetarian.
I would lean towards vegetarian because
I don't think there's anything wrong
with free range eggs and things along
those lines and I don't think there's
anything wrong with catching fish
either,
so maybe it'd be like a pescatarian,
but what I wanted to avoid was the whole
factory farming thing is fucked up.
It is completely.
So then I started hunting.
I was like,
it's going to be one or the other.
Once I started hunting,
I was like,
oh,
this is the way because this is exciting
and crazy and wild and it puts you in
tune with nature and this crazy way and
you have this deep,
intense respect for wild things that I
never had before.
I didn't think about the management of
wildlife or the resources of the land
that we have public land and that these
animals roam these areas and these areas
have to be supported with money and that
money comes from hunting tags and
attacks.
On sportsmen,
skier and sporting gear and you know,
anything,
hunting gear related,
they pay a giant.
Some of that money that goes towards
conservation.
It's a big tax.
He's like 11 percent.
Well yeah.
So this is like what supports that and
all the licenses and everything that
supports the fish and wildlife
management of this country or this wild
game.
It pretend that's why there's more deer
in this country than there has been
since Columbus landed because more dear
in this country.
Then when Columbus land,
it's not true.
Yes,
it is more white tailed deer in this
country than then there ever was before
and then there's other animals that they
had almost extirpated because of what,
what are call market killing and market
hunting.
They used to do at the turn of the
century back when they didn't have
refrigerators,
they would and they just took advantage
of these wild animals roaming around.
They would hire assassins essentially to
go shoot these animals and sell,
sell the meat,
and they almost wiped out all the elk.
They almost wiped out all the deer.
They almost wiped out everything at one
point in time before fish and wildlife
management company started managing all
this stuff.
There was a severe problem with the lack
of wildlife and the,
you know,
the possible impending instead
extinction price crisis,
but since then they've repopulated elk
and a lot of areas.
They repopulated dear almost everywhere
it was before.
There's a big family in New Jersey and
they're deer all over the place and I
always thought it was because there was
so much development that the deer have
nowhere to go.
Well,
it's because there's no predators,
right.
In New Jersey has more predators now
than ever before.
It was really New Jersey densest
population of black bears in the
country.
Really?
Yeah.
So those are the predators that control
the deer population,
but a lot of times that's not enough
food for them.
And then the encroaching population,
they find out about garbage cans and
things like that and then they become a
giant problem.
Right.
Because there's also the densest
populated with humans.
Well it is,
but it's not.
See,
New Jersey has a lot of really rural
areas that a lot of people aren't really
thinking about.
They're not aware.
There's a ton of wildlife in New Jersey.
People only think about like Newark,
which is where
I was born.
Yeah.
You know,
they think of northern New York,
New Jersey rather than clerking county.
That's where I was born in southern New
Jersey and then last the whole best
sell.
Fucking crazy.
Yeah,
it's crazy rural out there.
My,
my brother in law started to.
Similar to what you started thinking
about how he's going to get us food and
stuff and he started hunting deer and
because it's in New Jersey,
there's all these deer,
so he goes out,
he gets to a season and it feeds his
family for the year.
Yeah,
and amazing.
It is a thought.
First of all,
you're controlling a population that
needs to be controlled because there's a
ton of accidents.
2 million car accidents in this country
last year,
people hitting deer and 150 people died.
2 million from hitting deer.
Yeah.
In this country alone,
she's.
Yeah,
that's crazy high.
Unless you want to bring mountain lions
and wolves everywhere,
you have to figure out a way to control
those things,
but one of the best ways to control that
also contributes to wildlife management
funds is hunting rifle hunting tags.
See,
it's all.
It's all very counterintuitive because
we assume the people who don't like
wildlife,
right?
Oh,
you don't like it if you'd like total
out alone and let it.
Let it,
let it live.
It's life man.
But yeah,
but the problem is we've set up highways
and these cities and like you can't just
leave it alone.
Now.
We've already interfered in nature to a
point.
We've altered gigantic swaths of land to
suit our bidding.
So you either want to regress away from
technological.
So the people that drive tesla saying
this are the most crazy.
What?
Oh,
sorry.
You know what I mean?
It's like people who want cities and one
technology,
but they don't want management of
wildlife.
You don't understand it.
They don't even understand it.
They've been out there.
The city's not even possible unless you
manage wildlife.
Right?
Because of mountain lions and bears
start moving into Pasadena and start
killing people to manage them.
If deers are everywhere and everyone's
crashing into cars,
you can imagine.
What are you going to do?
How are you going to manage them?
It will.
Human shouldn't play God man.
Okay.
We'll just go outside and hope.
Hope you don't get eaten,
you know,
per se.
I would say a high percentage without
knowing anything,
uh,
of people at hunt.
Love the outdoors.
Love being out there.
But then you have those stories like you
were saying with the Ted nugent where
people just kinda come in with their
guns and shoot and get drunk and go off
those,
Frankie's,
he doesn't do that.
But he is a very boisterous right wing
type character.
No,
I'm seeing the guys who came in and just
shot his books and split those guys.
We,
yeah,
yeah.
I don't know if they were drunk or just
crazy or drunk.
Okay.
They were all cracked up and messed up.
Yeah.
They weren't crank around killing
bathtub crank.
Well,
I hope this,
this discussion doesn't dissuade you
from going to Musso.
And frank's gentleman in our sue has to
do what we've gotta do a Martini and a
steak once a year.
All those,
those cows once a year.
Um,
but this,
this meat that I eat last night that I
shot yesterday morning and ate that
night,
maybe the best thing I've ever eaten in
my life.
Really fucking picture on instagram.
That one.
So rich with nutrients.
Just looking at those pictures.
It's so.
It's so good.
My God.
It's so rich with nutrients.
So how did you cook that?
I cooked it on.
I have a pellet grill.
It's called a yoder.
It was a bunch of really good ones.
Trager makes it a really good one.
Green mountain grills makes really good
ones.
A bunch of companies that make them.
I cook it at 275 degrees until it hits
an internal temperature of 125 degrees.
Then it's not so long,
right?
No.
Then I take it off and then I heat up a
cast iron skillet.
This is.
I've tried a bunch of different ways,
but this is the method that works the
best for me that I liked the best.
I heat a cast iron skillet very,
very hot and then I put some grass fed
butter in a cast iron skillet and then I
see or the outside of put across.
So after the internal temperature is
already 125 degrees.
I cook it real quick.
So last in?
Yep.
Into the pan which is on the stove top.
Yeah,
like maybe less than a minute.
Each side maybe?
Yeah,
like maybe like 45 seconds,
maybe each side just to get a little
crust on that and it just is the perfect
combination of the outside and the
inside is very rare.
Light but warm.
It's like when you take a bite of me,
just start pounding the table and it
makes you feel physically good.
Yeah.
Not like Ligo.
Google your big mirror and killed an
animal.
That's not what I mean.
I mean like your body responds to the
nutrients and the meat in almost like an
instantaneous way and part of it could
be the thing that's very different than
going to Jerry's Deli and getting that,
but stromae is that there's an
incredible deep,
immediate connection with that food,
especially for me that day,
knowing that I shot that that morning.
How did you get it done?
So it doesn't have to go to the butcher?
No,
we take parts of the body off,
take the backstraps and the tenderloins,
which are like,
I'm very easy to manage.
Cuts a butcher shop.
We'll cut steaks out of the back legs
and the Hams and roasts and things like
that.
Gotcha.
So what did you,
what,
what was that piece that you had last
night?
Was the tenderloin that you just took
with you?
Yeah,
well,
I took a bunch of it with me.
Just put it in a cooler,
a Yeti cooler.
But dude,
it's a,
it's,
it's the total opposite of going to a
burger place where you just go,
yeah.
Can I get a double double?
Yeah.
Onions,
fries,
a large diet coke to please.
Right,
you get that and it's great.
I mean it tastes good and everything
like that,
but that's,
there's no connection,
nothing.
Whereas there's no thought.
It's insane connection and it's really
difficult to accomplish,
to shoot an elk with a bone arrow.
It's crazy.
It takes years and years of practice and
I still suck at it compared to like a
really good archer and a really good
hunter.
I'm still constantly practicing,
constantly trying to,
uh,
no.
I mean evolve it.
Like if I were to get into hunting and
go out there,
I'd have to take a gun because otherwise
I'm going to be shooting it in.
It's even that you have to learn how to
shoot a gun properly.
The snotty,
it's not.
People think it's easy
to go shoot an animal with a gun getting
close to one.
If you don't know what the fuck you're
doing,
you could look out and wander into a
deer is not paying attention to them,
but most of the time,
no.
Most of the time you have to get within
a couple of hundred yards of them.
You have to.
If the wind is wrong,
they smell you a mile away,
they fucking bolt immediately.
We stink doing.
We smelled terrible when animals smell
us.
I don't know.
I would.
I would wish science could figure out
what it is that hits an animal's
nostrils when they smell a person,
but like a deer.
They're like,
fuck this.
They're gone.
Really?
Yeah.
The wind hits the back of your neck.
See if your winds change.
Right?
So like say if you're looking at these
animals and you're trying to make a
stock on one and then the wind is
blowing in your face,
like this is perfect.
They can't smell me because the wind's
in my face.
Then as you get closer,
the wind can shift.
Sometimes the wind swirls and you feel
in the back of your neck and they just.
The animals perk up and they're like,
fuck right.
And they're gone.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
It's because they're thinking about
cats.
That's what they're thinking about.
They're thinking about smelling a cat
and that fucking that sent hits them.
Yeah.
This weird human scent.
The human things bad too.
I think we probably smell.
We'd probably have our own unique danger
smell,
but they're,
I mean,
they're,
the evolution is not to avoid humans.
We've only been here a couple of hundred
years.
The evolution of the ELC is most likely
to avoid predators.
Cats and bears that smell.
They smell a predator.
Right?
Fuck this,
you know,
go to the breath of a grizzly bear.
No,
and the lane hits you if you're a
fucking dear Jesus.
I saw coyote the other day out on my
neighbor's lawn.
It was like a Husky.
It was a big ass look like a wolf.
It's probably a Coi Wolf on the other
half.
There's.
Those are happening.
There's coyotes.
Well,
here's the thing.
There was a guy named Dan Flores that I
had on the podcast.
He wrote this book called Coyote
America.
Fascinating book with a history of
coyotes in America.
Oh yeah.
Can absorb that book.
It's so good.
Oh,
it's amazing because it's so crazy.
I know.
There's all the shit that I did know.
One of the things is that a coyote is a
wolf.
It is a small wolf.
It's a small species of walking.
That's why they interbreed with walls.
No problem.
Every wolf except the gray wolf,
the gray wolf left America for so long
and went to Africa and became like
jackals and all these different dog
species over there,
but all the dogs that we have,
all of them came from wolves.
All of them and all of our dogs,
my dogs,
every dog.
And they all can breed with a wolf.
Really?
All of them.
Yeah.
So.
And the coyotes,
they breed with different,
like a lot of coyotes.
Like what percentage?
Grey Wolf.
What percentage?
Red Wolf.
Like there's separate species.
They're all the same thing genetically.
Like every dog,
when they traced the DNA of a dog that
give,
give all of them come from wolves.
Real.
Yeah.
One of my little black lab.
The Coi Wolf?
Yeah.
You're a little black lab at one point,
you know?
Who knows what that process was a wolf.
So these coils,
you see the one in the black,
that's the Coi Wolf,
but it's like a combination of like a
wolf and a coyote that play.
Meanwhile,
even coyotes though,
this Guy Dan Flores,
we're saying are kind of wolf.
That's why it works in the first place
because they don't like if something
like a Tiger Fox align and they make a
lagger,
that lagger can have babies,
but because they're two totally
different species,
but at tiger can fuck a lion and get it
pregnant.
There's a real legacy.
It's about it.
Talk to you worried.
This was not the woods for you.
Uh,
it wouldn't go out of here,
buddy.
Let me get you back home to your
parents.
Not here comes a bear.
I'm protecting these kids.
You fuck dude.
You smell.
You smell terrible.
Get outta here.
So what you've seen is larger coyote.
This was a big coyote.
It was big.
I was like,
oh my God.
He might just be a regular coyote.
That's big to a lot of food out here,
man.
Man.
Mostly pets.
It's a lot of pets of pets.
A lot of bets,
man,
leave me.
We got light deal with coyotes as
opposed to those people in New Jersey
that are dealing with bears.
Yeah.
People.
People don't know.
People that live outside like go,
go to that video from far rockaway where
these two,
500 pound bear,
I might be exaggerating,
500 pound bears are rustling and
fighting in the street,
knocking over mailboxes in New Jersey
and cars stopped there.
Their Internet,
if I'm exaggerating,
it's not by much.
Look at these two things.
Oh man,
look at this size of these fuckers.
Dude looks like my sister's house.
But look how they fall down and they
knock shit over.
They slammed me.
They knocked over that fence post.
Look at the size of these fuckers and
they're fighting over territory.
They don't attack people though.
Sure they do.
They do.
Rockaway,
New Jersey.
A kid in rutgers was killed a couple of
years ago.
A kid in Alaska was killed by a bear who
was on look them go to their big.
A kid in Alaska was killed.
He was on a,
uh,
a race.
He was on a trail race.
Sixteen year old kid,
he called his mom,
said a bear was following them.
Oh my God.
And got a bear.
Got Him.
They,
they found the bear protecting the kids
body.
Look at the size of that fucker.
That's huge.
I felt black bears were small.
No,
that's bullshit.
They're cute.
I thought they were small.
How small do you think they were?
I thought they were like a smaller than
that.
With the size of that.
When they first are,
when they're babies grow it really big.
The ones at the junk.
Bam.
They get huge man.
Huge.
They get to be like eight feet tall.
She's.
Yeah.
So what's the Predator for the black
bear and New Jersey hunters.
That's it.
That's it bears on.
How many predators?
None.
Well,
the only Predator to a bears,
another bear,
which they do kill each other a lot.
They eat each other a lot.
Especially babies.
They eat a lot of babies.
They do.
Oh yeah,
a lot of babies.
How would this guy.
He's riding his mountain bike and he
sees that bear and fucking fall down.
I was like,
chooses.
We don't have them out here.
Get this panic.
He ever seen the one where the guy hits
the bear and his car and he fucking
screamed.
Holy Fuck.
No.
He's driving his car down this road,
going like 35 miles an hour and this
bear jumps out last minute.
Boom,
hits the sea,
hits the car,
and the bear goes.
Fall line runs off into the.
Into the woods.
Oh my God.
Probably died.
Yeah,
but watch it slowly.
Watch this is crazy.
Yeah.
Watch this shit.
He's driving his car.
Just having a good time.
Yeah.
I am just driving.
Oh.
Oh my God.
That's not even the one that's the daily
mail one.
And then ran into the woods.
Yeah.
There's another one that happens even
quicker.
This is a little different because it's
got a guard rail.
The other one,
the other video is there's a bunch of
trees to the side.
This is it.
Yeah.
North Carolina.
Watch this one who were just driving
along and thinking about the time and
why people used to run the world and
slavery was Mike.
God,
that thing's huge.
The Shit don't have a fucking bear.
I said the same thing again.
Oh Man.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
I want to go home and smoke a fucking
shit.
They couldn't be any better than if
somebody narrated over an accident like
that.
Oh,
it's terrible.
Home Smoking.
Fucking big blow.
He missed that part.
Oh my God.
That is scary.
I just hit a bear.
They're huge dude.
My sister in law just hit a deer.
She says like,
like,
uh,
you know,
Bergen County,
not a rural part.
My friend Cam lives in Oregon and one of
the guys in his neighborhood died
because someone in front of him hit a
deer and the deer went flying through
the air and his car was behind it and
the deer landed through his
windshield.
She,
it's just flying bone.
Here's,
here's the angry Vegan argument.
So you just went like,
oh,
these animals to go away so you can
continue destroying the world with your
stupid fucking car,
man.
Is that what you're saying?
So yeah,
there shouldn't be any wildlife
because they didn't convince you.
How about it's their land man?
How about if there's.
Well then you shouldn't be talking to me
because there'd be no computers and
their land.
You wouldn't survive either.
We carve off swaths of it for our own.
What we decide,
the cities or our nomad,
the cities aren't even real man.
This is something we build over their
sacred burial ground.
This is where the bears just
buried a young man talk to each other in
an ancient language.
You don't understand anymore.
We cannot look.
We all have our own little fantasy world
is.
Well,
the anthropomorphization that thing that
Disney movies did,
but they made animals talk that fuck
people up.
It really did fuck this up as children.
I really did.
It really did.
Yeah.
No,
I know.
I mean,
people think that's a joke.
I'm joking around.
I'm being dead serious.
I watched my kids are vegetarians
because my wife is was a big part of it
was seeing them as people like seeing
them with a little bow tie or like you
know,
it.
It really has an effect.
Of course,
especially when you're a little baby,
you know,
when you grow up watching Yogi bear
watching,
you know,
foghorn Leghorn,
but as a child,
when I was watching that stuff,
my mom was awesome.
Making amazing meals at the same time.
Did not connect it.
Now yogi was Yogi and mom just made
lasagna.
There's a real problem with representing
something.
I mean,
look,
it's entertaining.
It's nothing wrong with that.
For us as an adult child,
it puts the idea in your head that these
things are something other than what
they are.
Right.
You know,
not that there's anything bad with what
they are,
what they are is amazing.
Even predators,
like I don't.
I wouldn't want predators wiped out.
I think bears and wolves.
Fucking awesome man.
It's crazy to see too.
Oh no one around them.
Yeah,
and look,
I mean,
that's why the factory farming thing is
so gross.
There's a consciousness to animals.
My Dog,
you know?
Oh yeah.
It has a sensitivity and a love.
I mean,
is you make those animals suffer.
I mean that.
That's exactly.
That's the other thing is that animals,
especially dogs,
they have developed this intense
sensitivity in connection with people
over thousands and thousands of years of
having this weird symbiotic relationship
with us to the point where you get like
a,
like I have a golden golden retriever
do.
This is the sweetest dog I've ever had
in my life.
It was a big old snuggle bunny.
Yeah,
he's a baby and he's the sweetest thing.
Like occasionally he plays all little
too rough and everybody gets mad at him,
but it's such a sweet love bucket.
Like when I come home,
that dog,
he runs around me in circles,
then drops onto his back and I start
rubbing his belly.
Yeah.
I sit down and he climbs on top of me
and circles around and kisses my face,
licking like crazy with his legs up in
the air.
He wants to be a rub.
His Tummy,
the past.
It's the past.
He's so sweet.
You know,
they did a,
uh,
there was an article the other day,
which I didn't get too deep into,
but that they,
um,
this guy,
train dogs,
so they would be calm enough so you
could put them in an MRI.
You could actually study their brains.
Oh Wow.
It was hard to do because dogs like
freak out and that,
but you need them just to stay still
like a human.
So you can study their brain and they
learned that a lot of the patterns of a
dog's brain are similar to ours.
Empathy and feeling for things in motion
of like,
you know,
it was so similar that it really showed
like just genetically wired to feel an
and have emotion.
Very similar to the way we do.
That's fascinating.
You know what else?
So genetically wired to do kill
chickens.
Real problem.
Yeah.
Do you have chicken?
I don't know if he's killed one,
but he definitely brought a dead one to
me once when I was like,
did you kill this?
What the fuck happened?
Because it didn't make sense.
What do you mean?
Because he doesn't seem that aggressive
with the chickens before it might've
died.
Like they just die sometimes.
Sure.
They just die.
You find them in their pen?
Yeah.
The chicken coop.
They have this big ass,
like a chicken house.
Sometimes you just find them in their
debt.
Oh yeah.
You know there's where you get all your
eggs.
Yeah.
It's great.
They don't live that long,
you know?
But,
but he fucking,
now that he's had one in his mouth,
has carried it around,
found it.
Now he wants to go near them all the
time.
Like,
hey,
cut the shit.
Can you train them out to sort of.
Yeah.
But you got,
be on it all the time.
Yeah.
It's got to be like a daily thing.
Like he really likes chasing chickens.
Yeah.
He's like,
what are you talking about?
These are fucking
chickens.
No,
these are back here.
Had this thing since it was a big chase.
Chickens in their system.
It's instinct of course.
Oh yeah,
dude.
He's so happy too.
When you catch them doing it,
you know,
he just doesn't want to listen to my
dog.
Like it's great black lab.
She's so sweet.
Same thing.
And uh,
because we,
it's a vegetarian household,
it was only when I don't make meat that
often when I'm with the family because
it's just kind of,
you know,
it's kind of weird to be sitting there
eating meat in front of them.
So,
uh,
but when I do,
when we're alone,
sometimes they're giving her some meat.
She started to see me as the one thing
in the house that gave me whatever that
was.
Our relationship went to a whole nother
level.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Now she looks at me differently,
meet with butter on it.
They don't even bother chewing it.
You ever seen when you give them onto so
fast,
it's so gone.
So I really feel like,
no,
I enjoy that.
If you give them dog food,
they never react like that.
Like Lee does.
You're calling it chicken was chicken
shit.
I cut off a couple of peaks at ELC and
put it in my dogs food.
They're looking for more of time on the
bowl.
Under the bold.
She'd be gone.
Take your time.
Good instincts.
Yeah,
it's us.
It is a weird thing that we've created
these animals.
Not created them but sort of bred them
to the point where they become a part of
the household and they live with you,
but they don't speak English.
No rules.
They know the rules.
I've been kill you,
but they don't
when your dog sometimes like it's just
like your face to face.
He was looking you in the face
and you're just like,
and you just see the teeth and you're
like,
this is kind of weird that I my face as
close to this draw.
Thank God this thing is really nice
because it could just bite me in the
face right now.
That's why radic dogs like Cujo are so
fucking terrifying because they're a
part of your family.
Then all of a sudden something goes
wrong.
I had a job when I was a kid that we got
from the pound and had this temper and
we had them for a couple of days and it
just.
It kept getting worse and worse.
It was a Doberman Doberman Pinch.
Oh my God.
And it got to the point where was
growling and barking at us in the house.
Scared of everybody and grabbing a
barking.
Oh Man.
Where we were talking to it like what's
wrong,
what's wrong?
And then we brought it to the vet and
they were like,
this dog's fucked.
Really got this temporary.
It was just like a chemical thing.
It's some sort of a disease they can get
from other dogs and a lot of times dogs
that didn't have their shots,
they get it and it can make some dogs
behave very erratically and you can't
correct that.
I don't think they can.
At least they couldn't win.
I had a dog canine distemper,
contagious and serious viral illness.
No known cure disease affects dogs and
certain species of wildlife such as
raccoons,
wolves,
foxes,
and skunks.
Common House pet.
The Ferret is also a carrier of this
viral.
Oh my God.
So that was in your house?
Yeah.
Well,
it's not as bad as rabies,
but for this one dog,
whatever kind of distemper he had,
it was a major simpson as include high
fever,
reddened eyes,
watery discharge for the nose and eyes,
and in fact the dog come with chicken.
Tired usually become anorexic puppy that
had this as well.
And his his thing.
Well,
he didn't have this,
but he had something that gave him
seizures and they thought it was
distemper.
See fish seizures,
paralysis,
and attacks of hysteria seed.
That was what my dog had.
He had the hysteria part.
Oh yeah,
I don't know if he was lethargic.
He was just sitting there,
even though he's growing.
It wasn't like it was trying to get us,
but he wasn't doing that may result in
two to five weeks after the initial
infection that said,
yeah,
you have one dog at three.
You have three.
Yeah.
Do you think it's mean to have one dog
doesn't mean if you're around the dog
and hanging out with him every time.
It gets a lot of love dogs like dogs
though.
They do like dogs are pack animals.
Yeah,
they have a good time together.
Oh my God.
We had this little thing came over to
the house that was so happy.
My daughter's got a Chihuahua and so the
Chihuahua and the uh,
the golden get together and they run
around and play and it's like they have
the fucking best time,
like it's a part and I could go for
hours running around circles,
barking at each other.
I don't know.
I mean I'm like,
you know,
it's a lot of work having.
And I'm like,
one's enough.
But when I saw them together,
I had a little weakness,
like especially if it's a good size yard
where the around.
Yeah.
It's an okay.
So the crazy thing is that that used to
be a wolf even like an English bulldog
somewhere along the line that was a wolf
was a wolf.
They all come from that.
Yeah.
And then the wolves like slowly got
closer to us by the campfire.
We had food,
we chuck a little food.
He'd be cool to ask the other worlds.
So back off.
These guys go through.
They're cool,
they're cool,
they're cool man.
Then they became more and more
submissive.
They think over time,
one that were more submissive or more
accepted and they bred more and then
their ears started a flop more
submissive versus like the ears up,
like listening around for prey.
Right.
Instead they became this thing came to
know his dogs.
It's pretty great.
Fucking strange man.
Strange know that when they were.
Before they started doing those DNA
tests on dogs,
they thought that they would find that
dogs came from like a bunch of different
wild canids,
like a bunch of different wild dogs.
That's what I would think.
Yeah.
From North America to.
Because there's so different looking.
That's crazy heat map.
Well,
so our people though,
right?
I mean that's the weird thing about life
life.
Just,
that's one of the reasons why it's so
easy for us to like gather up into these
stupid tribes because visually we look
so much different.
Right?
I mean people from South Korea look way
different than people from Africa and
it's very different to not think of us
all as the same.
Yeah.
So you try bill up,
but the people that look similar to you
because you're scared of the other and
not even the look.
There's probably like within us,
there's traits that you don't even know
that you're recognizing.
Like when I'm around the Italians,
like there's something about it that's
comforting for sure.
You know?
Yeah.
That's why it's like really funny.
Not Funny,
but it's really odd when like super
light skinned black people are like
really radical black activists,
you know,
like,
hi,
are you making that for something here?
Like what's going on here?
It's just how you actually feel or you
like really want to gain acceptance in
this.
Try Super Hardcore tribes with knocking
you.
You have to like show your,
your,
you know,
because this one thing that a friend of
mine said WHO's black who was talking
about a black racism and he was like one
of the weirdest racisms that I've had to
accept his dark people versus a like a
lighter black skin light skinned light
skinned people will often times be
really racist to dark skin,
black people.
Interesting.
And I was like,
really?
She's like,
Oh yeah,
yeah,
there's a big difference difference
between how light skinned black people
feel about dark skin,
black people and vice versa.
And dark skinned black people,
racism within black people.
I was like,
whoa.
Yeah,
that's a whole mindset that uh,
was trying to understand.
Just give people enough time and they'll
eventually find a group to belong to
that.
They even inside the group,
like if you ask like the black people
who are light skin,
do they identify more with the dark
skinned black people or white people?
They'd probably see more of the dark
skinned black people.
This is obviously a great
generalization,
but these people that have these issues
with this thing,
but they probably in comparison to white
people like,
well I'm not that person,
right?
I'm one of these and more like that guy,
but this guy's not like me because you
know,
he's that and I'm this and then this is
my group and their group,
you know?
So even inside groups we have the
faction,
hard line Republicans versus a more on
the libertarian side outright.
Right,
exactly.
Just check my profile,
let you know what it's all about.
I'm thinking athletes,
super wonder person,
you know?
I mean,
that's kind of what it is a lot of ways.
there's good ideas behind all these
things.
Not withstanding,
especially when you're talking about
idea,
not race,
right?
Like good ideas behind being a Vegan,
even good ideas behind like a lot of
right wing Republican ideas like what
they're trying to do is noble,
right?
Yeah.
No,
absolutely.
In some gas it's the extremes.
It's the extremes.
It's saying that that my team can never
be wrong in any regard and it's just
been on a team period.
Just there's a lot.
You gotta accept a lot of bullshit if
you want to join a team.
Yeah.
Billy dropped the ball that.
Fuck.
Now we lose.
Screw that.
No Billy Twat get them out and get that
twice.
Twice the best word to lots of great
one.
My Quad is so good.
That Sargon of a guy was trying to say
it.
Tell me it was.
I was spelling.
Spelling it wrong.
It's not taught that.
It's that [inaudible],
but he's out of his mind twice.
How do you say?
Swat?
Swat.
Team,
You say you don't say Swat.
You fucking Cock sucker.
It doesn't have any.
First of all,
the idea of English people telling us
how to use their language is offensive.
That is really rude.
Can't tell me how to speak your
language,
English person back off.
We own it now.
My favorite variation of English though
is Australian because it's a very
distinctive version of ink.
It's not American,
you know.
No distinctive completely.
They're off in their own island to
making up their own rules.
Like my friend Adam,
my friend Adam Green tree,
who is,
by the way has the most exciting
instagram story on in the world right
now.
He's been living by himself in the back
country.
Bowhunting in Colorado.
Yeah,
totally struck out in Colorado.
He was there for like 20 days.
I started watching because I heard you
talk to him.
He bailed on Colorado and now he's moved
into the grizzly infested mountains of.
Well,
not only that,
the grizzly invested mountains of
Montana,
but not only that,
he documented officially documented
grizzly bears in Colorado where people
are saying there's no grizzlies in
Colorado,
and there's even a website deals with
it.
It says,
the people who say they cited a grizzly
bear in Colorado,
it's oftentimes like Sasquatch,
like you think you saw.
No.
He is an experienced outdoorsmen who's
been a bowhunter his whole life.
He knows what he's looking at and he
found several grizzly bears in the
mountains deep in the background and
recorded it.
Sixteen miles in.
Yeah,
I mean a little blobs moving around the
backwards.
Hard to see.
But,
but they're big and he said that is
absolutely 100 percent a fucking
mountain grizzly bear.
So they're moving into Colorado to.
He's been in the woods a long time,
20 days and now he's back.
He got in a car.
I rented a car to come a day.
He drove into a think Wyoming or Idaho.
Whatever's connected to Montana.
I think it's Wyoming.
No,
Idaho.
Think it's Tido.
Yeah.
He drove into Idaho and now he's making
his way down from Idaho into the parks
in Idaho and he's hiking into Montana,
into grizzly infested back in Wyoming.
Coming from the south.
It's fucking scary shit man.
There's grizzlies everywhere up there.
He,
uh,
has a family.
Yes it does.
And he's just out in the woods to be
scared.
I'm not scared.
I'm what?
I'm envious of how he gets out of his
house to go to the woods for 20 days,
20 days.
My wife would let me.
Well,
if you were already,
love it.
If you're updating your instagram story
constantly.
See,
that's my theory as to why he's doing
this.
This way.
He lets everybody know where he is all
the time.
Everybody knows he's okay.
Versus like him just disappearing off
the map for 30 days.
Right.
It is so interesting that you could be
out there and be able to film stuff and
communicate and look at maps and he's a
savage.
Not a lot of people can do it that way.
Even most bowhunters will tell you,
like,
man,
I'll go for a back country camping trip
for like seven days by myself for 10
days,
but this guy is just gone so deep.
He's in by yourself,
by himself.
That's,
that's the thing.
I mean even even one other friend makes
a big difference.
He ran out of food while back,
so you could see him like getting
skinnier and skinnier.
As time went on.
He had to go into town and get more
food.
Oh my God,
and ran out of food.
You see it in his face,
like his face is getting more gaunt.
His eyes are getting more sunken in and
it's like,
oh,
I saw.
I'm like exhausted.
At one point he was just like laying
back.
So deep man.
I mean what he's doing,
he had a filter water through a piece of
a wet.
Oh,
like old rotting piece of wood.
He poured the oil because his filter was
back at Camp 16 miles away because he
had been running.
He'd been getting so much fresh water
that was pumping right out of the ground
from springs.
You could just drink that,
but when you come to a creek like you
have to take a chance because he could
be Giardia [inaudible],
beaver's shit and the dam and you get
what they call beaver fever.
Oh boy.
You Shit.
Your brains like rocket projectile,
broken fire hydrant,
diarrhea.
Just where your body's like,
Hey,
fuck.
Had He.
I saw him taking a sip and saying,
I might regret this apple days.
Oh Man.
Yeah.
He drinks a lot of straight out of the
ground and he just doesn't.
This is Gig.
Well,
he has a company in Australia and he's
kind of his own boss,
so he gets to decide that he goes on on
the road 30 days at a time and do this,
but he's a very famous professional
bowhunter too.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Crazy insta story.
If you're interested.
It's like for these guys that want to do
these back country solo haunts,
but it's.
There is.
Look at his face in the far left.
He asked a lot of weight and yeah,
he had a little.
He's going to be shredded when he gets
off the mountain pose for a fucking
calendar.
He's a handsome fella,
isn't it?
It's so funny.
Like it's amazing.
Like just social media.
It's like you watch him and he's like
out in the woods by himself.
Then the next story is,
hey,
the my,
my show,
my show at the ice house.
It's really having a good time.
I know he's crazy.
He's pretty hard because different
lives,
you know,
but I was gonna say their,
their version of the English language is
the best.
He'll say,
you know,
but I've got my tent and got me go over
here.
I've got me water supply,
I'm all good.
Everything's me.
This me that.
That to me is like my favorite version
of the English language.
Like English sounds slightly cooler than
American [inaudible],
but Australia and slightly cooler than
English.
That's the most to learn English
language sounds a little,
uh,
sends a little reckless to me.
Do you think so it's a reckless
language.
Wound up everything.
Kill them over there.
Wound up,
yeah.
They got to be wound up fucking snakes
and spiders and crocodiles and they're
surrounded by sharks.
They're all out there on their own to
tax them because no one,
no one is going to help.
Yeah,
I mean,
how big is the Australian army?
It's like 25 people I think.
Well,
the whole place is only as the amount of
people.
It's the same size as America,
but the amount of people is the same as
California.
Slightly less than.
Oh,
that sounds great.
I'll just drive around.
I was just saying this before to Jamie
that I think living in La,
I just feel like I'm going to end up the
cranky guy that can't be around people.
I.
There's so many people around us all the
time.
Yeah.
It just,
it's exhausting.
It is,
but it's also energizing,
right?
Somewhat.
When I come back from the woods might go
somewhere like.
Especially camping.
Yeah.
And then you come back to civilization.
You kind of appreciate restaurants and
movie theaters.
Yeah.
Get some popcorn and watch a movie.
Just like being around it.
Maybe that's it.
You just need breaks from it.
That's what I think.
Yeah.
I think the best of both worlds is both
worlds,
right?
I think just living by yourself in the
woods,
like the unibomber,
like what the fuck,
dude,
I don't want to end up that way.
Their loan with nature,
nature.
No fucking phones.
Pussy.
What's going on?
Do that.
Total military personnel.
Eighty 1000.
We have $81,000
military in my house.
No amount of military that America.
What's the amount of military in
America?
Yes.
Let's guests before we search.
How many people are in the United
States?
Military members?
We're not even gonna.
Include the coast guard.
You have to include the Coast Guard,
Navy,
Coast Guard,
marines,
air force,
army.
4 million.
Eighteen million.
70 million.
70.
I'm going crazy.
No.
Three,
two point six.
Two point three rather than the total
population.
Three 23.
Well,
they're not including mice is ran at
$23.
Million then total military.
Two million.
300.
Wow.
So less than 10 percent.
You know what's interesting about that
number,
man?
I remember when $250 million when they.
When I was a kid,
the population was 250.
I remember because I remember thinking
me and my friends were sitting around.
We were in high school.
We were like 250 million.
Yeah.
How the fuck are there?
That many people?
Yeah.
We were like,
wow,
now it's almost 100 million more.
My God in the world.
It's like 7 billion.
But what was it then?
I think.
I think in like the eighties when I was
in high school.
I bet there was a half.
Yeah,
I bet there was like three.
we've met,
we've learned to survive to.
Well,
it's amazing.
So many people got all this food shipped
into these cities and Madison factory
farming and medicine are living longer,
living much longer,
longer,
so many people during the last eclipse.
That's what the stat that blew my mind
during the last time we had an eclipse,
total eclipse like that on our,
uh,
on our continent.
It was 100 years ago,
100 years ago.
There were fewer people in the whole
state of California than who live in La
today.
Oh,
it must be nice.
must have been.
Gloria gets to the comedy store in like
10 minutes on a bike.
It was rolled out in the world.
Sweet.
My,
it was like a small town.
So many damn people.
Nineteen 17.
There's 3 million people in California
in the whole state.
That's way less than la million.
Three people and they were probably
like,
there's so many fucking people gross.
I can't go to town one more time running
into those asshole.
What is today,
Texas?
What does Texas have today?
Go to the very end here.
Texas has 27 million Canada,
the entire country of Canada.
Thirty 6 million.
Oh my God,
I'll fornia $39 million.
So California has more people than
fucking Canada,
so I'm not going crazy.
It's a real thing.
Yeah.
Well that's also one of the reasons why
California or the Canada,
the people are so nice.
They're not as overwhelmed.
Yeah.
They're surprised to see you see that,
that bear on the fucking California
signed.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
That bears that are extinct in
California.
What is that?
That's a grizzly grizzly.
They used to have grizzlies in
California.
In fact,
the last grizzly that killed a man in
California before they killed him was in
Lubbock,
back California.
There's a guy that was the last guy
killed by a bear in California.
His name,
I think it was Stephen Labeck something
l e b,
e c,
and they named the town after him.
He was the last guy in California to be
killed by bears.
We used to have huge bears in the 1800.
Think it was.
I think it was then the 18 hundreds,
but they killed them because they were
killing all the people,
like they were killing us.
It was us or them,
but meanwhile it's damn we put on the
flag like we won,
but we miss you buddy,
so puts you on the flag.
We love you.
We will.
We love looking at you,
but you've got to stop eating us.
And so we had to shoot you all.
You know.
It's lame about that is a,
it's similar to what happened with the
native Americans,
but it's not think it is.
You know what most we killed most of the
native Americans in this country.
Disease.
Smallpox,
like a bunch of diseases.
Can we present that?
We brought to them.
Yeah.
That crazy.
Ninety percent of them were killed.
Wiped out by disease.
Yeah.
I was taught.
We killed them all.
We killed a lot of them for sure.
Not We.
I shouldn't say we.
I was just reading the grandchild of
immigrants.
Yeah.
I was just reading exactly what we were
in Italy at the time,
enjoying ourselves.
There was a lake.
The Tinaya Lake in a yosemite is named
after this chief Tinaya who we killed
his son.
We killed his son in front of him.
We should stop saying way.
I know it wasn't.
I feel guilty.
I had,
I had that in my act for a while.
My daughter was like,
why did we do that?
I'm like,
easy with the.
We,
we were on vespas and eating spaghetti
were lovers a uh,
and then named the lake after him killed
his kid in front of him,
made him suffer,
killed him,
and then named the lake after him.
It's like,
it absolves us of the guilt and we're
just step out tonight or there was some
horrible,
horrible shit going on back then.
Horrible all over the world.
I mean,
and even before that,
like the accounts of what Columbus did
when they encountered the natives and
then,
you know,
they're trying to get gold out these
people and slaughtered these people.
Slaughtered.
I mean,
just serial killer type shit.
that's.
We used to have Columbus to.
I guess we still do,
not,
not in California.
They're getting rid of it.
They voted it apple debt.
Yeah,
that's a good idea.
But in New York,
uh,
you know,
Columbus circle and they still have the
somewhat deface the Columbus,
a statue in central park.
The other day I stopped doing that man.
Just like you gotta stop,
you can't deface gingiss con statue.
It's one thing to revere and worship
these people and we definitely shouldn't
do that anymore.
But like to those statues are history.
We should look at it but understand what
we're looking at.
But we're not worshiping the statue of
Christopher Columbus.
But it is a fascinating thing to know
that this monster got in a boat and sail
across the ocean.
If it wasn't for him,
likely wouldn't be a whole population
here and the people that he went with.
I think you've got to add some new
statues,
statues of other people that had a
positive impact on stuff.
You know.
You know what's fucked up though about
a lot of these civil war statues that
people are wanting to tear down now and
destroying it's fucked up was when you
look at when those things were built,
those things weren't built like way
before the civil rights movement and
there are a relic of an ancient past.
A lot of them were built in response to
the civil rights movement.
So they really are racist and origin.
Yeah.
A lot of the Robert e Dot Lee ones and
all that shit where the world and the
south going to rise again and yeah.
No,
they weren't around since the 18
hundreds.
It was like 65 and line from a made
really quickly and shittily in response
to the civil rights movement and that
they were made out of copper and bronze
and shit cause it was easier to do than
stone.
Oh really?
Yeah.
No,
it's not good.
Now we had to create some other people,
like a visualization of the number of
monuments that were erected and what,
how awesome.
These are all civil war monuments.
Uh,
yeah.
We'll get that shit.
Naacp was found a giant spike in civil
war monuments.
Wow.
Look at that,
man.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
It was a retaliation summer race riots,
giant spike and civil war monuments,
Tulsa race riots.
Giant spike in civil war.
Civil war statues.
That's nuts,
man.
Yeah,
like you could track it.
A bigger version of this too.
I was trying to find right now,
but we got this little chunk.
That's spooky.
Yeah,
because no one's talking about that when
they're talking about keeping these
things up and they represent our
heritage,
like yeah,
I understand what you're saying,
but worshiping this is a real problem
because you got to realize what was the
motivation to put like why is it okay
though for me?
Why?
Why do I look at it and go,
I have a problem with this because they
did it during the racist 19 sixties or
during the early 19 hundreds and the
naacp was created.
I would accept it better if it was 200
years old instead of 100.
Like what's wrong with.
Right?
Like why do I care?
Right.
What do you mean?
Why?
I mean,
why?
Why is it like,
I mean,
why is it more offensive that it was
created by racists in the 19 sixties
than if it was created by racist 200
years ago?
Maybe it's because,
like I said,
direct line people alive right now.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
That's dirty.
It's dirty.
When you look at the actual spikes.
Yeah.
George Wallace.
It jumped up during the assassination of
Martin Luther King Jr.
Woo.
When George Wallace was blocking the
school's jumped up a whole bunch.
That's Weird.
Yeah.
Detroit race riots.
Boom.
We got a little spike hanGing onto it.
Not so fast.
Teams at war.
Yeah.
Act of kindness.
That's not an act of kindness.
That's putting a statue up there out of
out of love.
Do you ever think though that those
people that Were doing all this stuff
back then,
they really didn't have a direct
connection with the world the way we
have today and then one of the reasons
why we're seeing all these people
tearing these things down now is because
we all have a direct connection with
each other and we realized that,
hey,
these civil war,
they're fucking horrible.
What the civil war was,
was horrible,
like saying that it's a part of your
culture.
This is horse shit.
Like,
no,
this is a part of a terrible attempted
genocide on black people did demonizing
to the point where they were the other
and it was okay to enslave them hundreds
of years.
No.
You could live in in New York state and
not have any idea really what was going
on
the south at the time.
No,
no,
no.
You don't understand.
The civil war was about economics.
I've seen that argument too,
but I've seen an argument torn apart.
If there was social media back then,
do you think slavery would have even
existed?
No,
and here's the thing.
Nobody wants slavery today.
If you do,
you're a cunt too.
It doesn't mean that when you guys
define yourself by a war that you lost
and the war had a big part of what the
war was about.
Slavery.
That's a giant problem.
It's a big giant problem.
And how the world looks at us and looks
at you and the way you look at yourself
like you're.
Yeah,
you're justifying some of the most
horrific shit in human history so far
from american history.
Yeah.
That's not out of kindness.
Slavery.
They actually live better.
That argument.
Better slaves.
Oh gee,
that's weird.
Wouldn't how strange is it that people
live better when you fed them and they
lived in fucking cages then when they
were released with no skills and no
education and couldn't read and how to
repopulate,
and I'm like in a country that they
don't even.
It's not even a country of their origin
as you're still putting up a statue on
your way out the door of the fucking
general who fought to keep slavery
alive.
Let's move on.
It doesn't mean that the south is an
awesome folks.
It doesn't mean that you're not awesome,
you know,
but let's move forward.
Stop with the teams.
Here's the problem,
right?
What do you do about old leonard
skinner,
the albums that fucking fly that flag
represent to the dukes of hazzard.
I know.
Yeah,
Own neil young.
IT's tricky.
It's like all things.
It's not that black and white.
You can absolute.
That has some awesome shit.
Well,
they also don't want to,
there is a danger in wiping out history,
so we don't learn from it.
Like you can't do that either.
Like you can't just pretend this thing
didn't exist and that there's remnants
of it still around.
You need to be educated,
have,
if we're going to learn from history,
you need to educate yourself about it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So you can't just sweep it all unDer the
rug and think,
okay,
if we don't see it,
it didn't exist.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
and on that note,
tom papa was bringing his pitch home.
This cigar was so nice.
Very good.
So great.
What's it,
what's it called?
A believer?
oliva oliver oliver.
Hopefully created by highly skilled,
well compensated craftsmen and women.
Are you swimming?
Are you a.
You're going on the road for a Bit on
the road again,
cranking it out.
I'm doing the comedy store saturday.
I'm gone
most of next Week and then that I'm
banging out a bunch of shows.
Whoa.
Nice.
October sixth,
vegas,
las vegas,
Nevada.
Ladies,
gentlemen hat,
the mother fucking moron.
I'm going to be gone for about a month.
Where are you going?
Bitch?
Everywhere.
Tom.
Papa.com.
Yeah.
That's where all my dates are.
Oh,
shit.
pacific north west.
The south,
the north,
northeast.
And if you have not seen tom,
papa is one.
God damn hilarious.
Standup comedian.
So go out and see him live.
You fucks.
I'm glad we got this in.
This was a nice treat.
I didn't think I'd see him for awhile.
Fucking fun,
man.
Yeah,
always the best.
And I got some elk for you.
Here we go.
You're the best buy guy.
See a girl.
Girls to bugger off soon.